the hearing will please come to order
mr. Lyman please proceed good morning
mr. seacord and
my correct mr. seacord that from
December 1984 until July 1985 you were
engaged in selling arms to the Contras
Laprade that's correct
and is it true that you brought in to
that venture mr. Hakim correct and
Newland Hakim were equal partners yes
and you also brought into that venture
Tom Klein's later yes and you and he
also participated in the profits
yes and you brought in Quintero yes now
did you choose to operate this on sale
venture through Panamanian corporations
yes and those corporations were energy
resources and later lengths
correct correct and did you choose to
handle the funds through Swiss accounts
yes and you understood that by doing so
you were enjoying the protection of
Swiss secrecy laws am I correct with we
thought so at the time
and did you in fact sign a fiduciary
agreement with a man by the name of
zipper to manage your money yes I
volunteered this information to you so
that the profits that you would be
receiving out of this venture would be
handled by mr. Zucker by his company yes
and were you and mr. Hawking equal
partners in energy and lake technically
no my name is not on any of those
accounts but in fact mr. Hakim responded
to my directions well was your
understanding with him that you would
share the profits equally yes but the
companies were nominally his correct now
would you tell us what your share of the
profit was from these sales of arms to
Claro
as I testified earlier the amount of
several hundred thousand dollars in not
checking the records of mr. Hakim that
you have showed me I haven't been able
to put a precise number on it is it your
claim that you did not know at the time
how much money you were making I did not
know the exact amount I didn't concern
myself with it you never asked Hakim he
kept me advised in a general way but I
did not have a precise number well
within a general way did he tell you
whether in his job a thousand four
hundred eight hundred a general way I
just told you mr. Lyman's several
hundred thousand dollars that's a very
clear answer
what is several hundred thousand mean to
you I cannot be more specific
you weren't more specific with him no
you weren't concerned about what the
amount of money was not particularly I
the money was a matter of indifference
to you
he's answered the question was the money
a matter of indifference to you it was a
matter of little concern to me at the
time I was busy with a lot of big
problems I couldn't worry about that is
it a fact mr. seacord
that the amount that you had credited to
your capital account was about four
hundred thousand I don't know as an
amount of several hundred thousand
dollars and I don't think that we can
determine from the records what that was
was it cabbie tried the other day to do
that was it kept for you under a
pseudonym in Switzerland
no under my name did you use the name
Korell Kor
no did you ever hear the name Corps yes
that's one of the companies that Hakim
organized did you have any interest in
coral coral was not my company did you
have any interest in corals
any more so than the other companies no
did you have any interest in coral I
just answered the question you said any
more than in the other companies what
was your interest in all the companies
and what was your interest in coral no
specific interest in coral was it ten
percent twenty percent 50 percent I
didn't have any percentage interest in
coral I don't know what you're getting
at well you had an interest in it but it
wasn't translated into a percentage no
absolutely not
then what was the nature of your
interest in it the same as the other
companies
are you saying that you had an undefined
interest in coral and the other
companies that's correct
I had a profit sharing arrangement with
mr. Hakim as I described to you earlier
and that was the limit of my interest
and that profit sharing agreement or
arrangement was 50 percent that's
correct
now you became a partner of Hakim right
after you left government perhaps four
or five months after I left government
and that was in the company called
Stamford technology trading grouping yes
sir now is it your testimony that in
July or August of 1985 you waived all
interest in profits I testified to that
earlier yes and there's not the fact of
course it's the factor I wouldn't have
testified to it and is it a fact that
you then no longer had any interest
whatsoever in late or energy or any of
those other company's profit interest no
is it when you say no you had no
interest no profit interest did you have
some other economic interest in those
companies of course I they had to remain
viable where the projects couldn't go on
well what was the nature of your
economic interest in those my personal
economic interest yes none did you have
some economic interest other than a
personal one yes the enterprise had to
remain viable or we would have gone
bankrupt and the project would have
failed and in July and August of 85 when
you waived this interest the project was
aiding the countries yes now when you
waived your interest
did you formalize that in any writing no
as I testified yesterday no did you tell
anyone other than Hakim and Zucker no
did you ever receive any document
indicating that the money that had been
accumulated for you was no longer there
no to the extent of the profits that
were then being held for you were you
just making a gift of them to mr. Hakim
I forced for them and left to mr. Hakim
to do with it as he wished and so that
they then became Hawkins money those
companies well when you say those
companies did you have profits from the
on sales and any other companies I don't
know where he distributed profits we've
been going through the records trying to
identify them did you ever ask Hakim at
the time where the profits were that
were being held for you no now you're
still a partner of Hakeem's I'm a
partner of mr. Hakeem's in Stanford
technology trading group international
and is still trying to do different
deals with mr. Hakim well I haven't had
time to do too many deals with mr. Hakim
but we're trying to get our lives back
together now have you been trying
recently to come up with some proposals
for deals with mr. Hakim yes we've met
several occasions to discuss business
have you ever requested of mr. Hakim
that he tell you where your money was no
and he's never written on my money
he's never refused to share with you
information about where the money was
that you earned correct he has not
discussed any of the details of these
accounts with me since the revelations
of November 25th and on the advice of
his counsel he has refused to show me
any of the records well before November
25th of 1985 did he discuss the accounts
with you in a general way we tried it
generally as you know
my records too to keep track I did try
generally to keep track of the money are
you saying that you never in that period
when you were talking to him before
November 25th estimate how much profit
there was as I told you earlier I went
with him on about four different
occasions in 86 to try to reconcile the
books the books were in disarray the
various disbursements were frequently in
the wrong operating companies the books
were were not in neat shape I was trying
to help him straighten them out we never
got around to get into that job finished
so that it is not so that the first time
that you had access to these books was
when you saw them in the committee rooms
here in preparation for your testimony I
have seen some of the records in the
past that I'd never saw a complete set
like I saw him in the committee had two
ever asked to see a complete set No what
was the purpose of your looking at the
books before gee I thought I just
answered that question to try to
straighten them out yes
and who told you that they were in
disarray mr. Hakim did mr. Hakim have
accountants working for yes did he have
Zuka working for him yes and they
weren't able to keep the book straight
is that to test no and do you know why
this is a covert operation and he
couldn't inform them of the outlines of
the operations and so they were
constantly making errors was there money
coming into the bank accounts yes
was there money going out of the bank
account yes
were there balances in the bank accounts
that wasn't the problem
did you ought to look and see the bank
records before you met in the committee
rooms here
no I've never seen the bank records you
ever asked to see the bank rep no did
you have a sign any document that gave
you access to the bank rec never did you
why did you choose not to ask
keen to see the bank records I didn't
think they were important did you not
think it was important to know how much
money there was that was generated by
this enterprise he was telling me I knew
what the deposits were and you know what
the expenditures were generally now even
after you told Hakeem that you didn't
want an interest in the profits were you
controlling the expenditures I was I was
directing him to make the expenditures
in support of the various projects is it
a fact mr. seacord that after august
1985 all of the funds that were
generated in these bank accounts came
from your efforts yes and is it a fact
that all of the expenditures were
expenditures that you directed be
expanded
the general answer to that question is
yes however I'd like to qualify the
answer by saying that mr. Rahim probably
made some expenditures from his profits
that I would have no idea of now did you
know what his profits were generally and
was mr. Hakim to receive a profit on the
sale of the weapons to Iran no and was
that because you and he agreed that that
would be done on a non-profit basis that
is correct and the profits fir from the
Iran sale would have be dedicated to
another purpose am I correct that that's
correct and is it a fact that you told
oliver north that you would not be
making profits from the iran sale i did
not tell him that did you tell him that
you would be making profits i didn't
tell him anything about it he never
asked you know he knew it was a
commercial enterprise he assumed that we
were making some money but between you
and Hakim you agreed that you would make
no profit on that on those transactions
that's correct
and is there any other occasion that you
can think of where mr. Hakim decided to
go into a commercial venture for no
profit no but he was already making
profits in the wet and the arms sales
and I thought that was fair enough well
the profits that he was making in the
arms sales were the sales to Klara right
at the contra and those sales amounted
to what about ten eleven million dollars
that's what we added up the other day
yes and you said that the markup on
those was about averaged about 20
percent correct that's correct so that
the profits on those would have been
about gross about two million dollars
[Applause]
hakim calculated those profits that that
was in that range and I don't have the
exact numbers and of those two million
dollars some of it was originally
allocated to you correct originally yes
yeah no nothing like that
some of it too to mr. Klein's yep and
after what was allocated to Klein's the
balance was allocated half to you and
hit the Hakeem original except that some
payments were also made to mr. Quintero
for his efforts and after that expense
the rest was divided between us and just
as we've said about four times now and
no profits on me of the fifteen million
dollars that you've testified the other
day from the uranium sales what to be
kept by Hakeem or you clam the number is
14 million and that's correct isn't it
14 million exclusive of the million
dollars you received from Israel in
November I accounted for that in my
testimony isn't it 14 million dollars
exclusive of that million exclusive of
that 800,000 yes well whether it's 14
million of 14 million 800 your testimony
here today was the hot team was not to
keep any of that that's right and I
think the bank records show that as you
be aware by now and the eight million
dollars that is now in some bank account
really is not money that belongs to
Hakeem or you is that correct no the
counselor
to restate the question police er where
is the 8 million dollars that is being
held today under the control of mr.
Hakim the House Counsel read that into
the record and as far as I know it's
correct but the where the state is
correct where is it there's something
over a million dollars in a Swiss bank
account and the balance according to mr.
Hakeem's testimony is being held by a
fiduciary on his behalf
what's the name of the fiduciary who's
holding it I don't have any idea in what
bank I have no idea you never asked him
I did but there's no communication on
that point but that's money that was
generated by the Iranian arms sale
correct correct and on the basis of your
testimony that's money that doesn't
belong to mr. Hakim correct I didn't say
that I said that in my testimony that
the money is the money of the enterprise
the money is the money of the enterprise
and who owns the enterprise mr. Hakim is
the technical owner and is there a
beneficial owner other than mr. Hakim no
so mr. Hakim is both the technical owner
and the beneficial owner that's correct
and yet you said a moment ago that Hakim
was not to get any of the profits out of
the Iranian arms sale that was our plan
so that the eight million dollars that's
out there now is just being kept but it
isn't profit that's a different issue
mr. Liman as you well know there in the
first place there are many bills that
have yet to be paid outstanding against
this enterprise bills that have to be
paid I don't know how much is going to
be left after these bills are paid and
I'm not focusing on it right now
I've got bigger problems to focus on
than that
I've got a special prosecutor over here
across the street that's trying to throw
all of us in jail for performing our
duty as we saw it I've been focused on
some technical issue like you're
bringing up here this is crazy
well was it part of your your duty to
keep this eight million dollars of
course it was part of our duty to keep
the eight million dollars we handed in
there for operating revenue I didn't
terminate this operation the operation
was blown apart the operation was
aborted so is it that was a snapshot
that existed at that time is what you're
saying that you expected that if the
arms sales continued to go forward you
would need to use this money to keep the
enterprise going correct so that the
enterprise could continue as a vehicle
for the Iranian arms sales as correct
isn't it a fact mr. seacord that in the
case of every sale of arms that you made
to Iran you got paid by Gabbana far
before you paid any money out to the CIA
no is there an instance that you can
recall where you didn't get the money up
front no you said if I go by far in the
October transaction we were paid by the
Iranian government okay you're a very
literal man so let me be literal too in
every instance of sales to Iran you
received the money up front before you
laid it out to the United States gretna
correct and is it true that in every
instance the amount that you received up
front exceeded which the cost was
charged by the CIA and the
transportation costs correct and is it
still your testimony that you had to
keep eight million dollars in order to
keep this going the figure went up as
the as the project went on as I
testified
already on several occasions there came
a time when we needed halt insurance on
aircraft that
finally I came to an amount of four
million that's half of your 8 million
right there there are bills that have
not been paid as I've told you now oddly
you ought to do a little bit of
arithmetic and a little thinking on this
well let's do some arithmetic on it you
said you said that on the first
transaction you had of a thousand toes
there was one plane that was involved
correct right and you had to guarantee
the Israelis that you would make good
for the cost of the plane if it didn't
return from Teheran correct correct and
so you set aside two million dollars
correct that's right and when and you
put it into a certificate of deposit
correct yes sir and that certificate of
deposit was under control of the
enterprise that's correct
and that plane did in fact return safely
to Israel correct yes sir and then you
kept the two million dollars correct it
kept it in a CD that's right but the CD
was kept by mr. Hakim correct why I
wonder well maybe others will 1 2 2 I've
already inserted the next I don't think
others will wonder I've already answered
the question was the plane back safely
in Israel yes
was it your position that if the
Israelis lost the plane on some mission
of their own you're going to give him
the two million dollars sure so that
after you had returned the plane to
Israel so that the Israelis could use it
for whatever they wanted you were going
to give them the two million dollars
onto the plane trying to tell us no
that's not what I'm telling you
you know that everyone knows that Italy
should arrest miss mr. seacord there
then was another trick correct yep and
that involved two planes that you had to
have ready right actually only one of
them made the trip to Tehran but the
other started to make the trip before
sail back and there you put aside in a
CD four million dollar in additional two
million yes sir that you had four
million dollars in rent though something
happened to those planes correct yes sir
and those planes returned safely to
Israel yes and you kept the four million
that's right and when you're sitting
there when you were sitting there in
November after the publicity developed
about the arms sales you still were
holding CDs correct yes sir and we were
and we were still planning future
operations and what did you have an
Israeli plane then that you were were in
surely no in fact we were talking to the
second channel about buying an airplane
and if you chose to ball a plane you
would use this money sure were you going
to borrow this plane from the second
channel for the second channel yes and
as a matter of fact we contacted
Southern Air Transport to start a search
for a 707 they found one and we were
proceeding to with the plans to buy that
Eric how much was that gonna cost the
asking price was about two million we
hoped we could have negotiated down to
1.5 or so and was this your decision
that you should buy the 707 yes
was it Oliver North's he wasn't involved
but there was a management decision that
was a management decision the monies was
your or yours to spend the enterprise's
yes now your position is that you have
absolutely no interest in any of these
Swiss bank accounts am I correct that's
correct
and you have nothing to hide in whatever
is in those records in the Swiss bank
accounts is incorrect and in fact you've
come here to testify voluntarily and I
came to you and went through the records
with you and tried to help you identify
various unknowns deniability
mr. seacord before mr. Hakim turned over
those records did you meet with him in
Geneva yes and did you discuss with mr.
Hakim the fact that he was turning over
records yes I met him with counsel did
you discuss with him which records
should be turned over and which
shouldn't know did you look at the
records that he was going to turn over
no his lawyers would not allow me to
look at the records who suggested that
you go to Geneva may I at this moment
advise counsel that if he wishes to
interpose an objection he should address
the chair and not mr. Lyman I will serve
I would like to interpose an objection
based on attorney-client privilege mr.
seacord did there come a time when the
United States government requested the
Swiss to provide the full records of the
Swiss bank accounts involved in the
Iranian and Contra transactions yes
did you notwithstanding your testimony
that you had no interest in these
accounts interpose an objection to that
request correct did you go to court in
Switzerland opposing that request yes I
relied on counsels advice did you pay
counsel to oppose the
request for records of accounts in which
you had no interest
well I relied on my counsels advice and
that's what we did and were you doing
that as a matter of principle
I relied on counsels advice well you're
doing that and order it uphold the
sanctity of the Swiss secrecy laws I've
answered the question did there come a
time when the Senate committee asked you
to waive Swiss secrecy yes sir and you
successfully oppose that request in
court is that correct that's correct
and you paid again fees to oppose the
request for inspection of records in
which you had no interest well I wish
I'd been able to pay fees but since I
don't have any money to pay these fees
my lawyer has not gotten any funds for
that action in court well don't you I
owe it yes so you incurred an obligation
yes sir in order to oppose a request for
records which you're telling this
committee or committees you have no
interest in that's correct
and am I correct that you answered
yesterday that you haven't yet decided
whether you're prepared to waive I
believe my answer was that I probably
will sign the waiver I'm inclined to do
so I have to consult with my counsel on
this matter just as soon as these
hearings are over but you've had some
four months to consult am I correct
they're not on this particular request
we didn't know we were going to be asked
to do this I didn't know that I was
coming up here voluntarily to appear
before you I didn't come here
voluntarily to be badgered by these
questions that I have answered already
repeatedly have you not had this request
before year since January to waive I
relied on the advice of my counsel let's
get off the subject you're making the
rulings no sir but I did not come here
to be badgered and you are not prepared
as
today to say that these records can be
available to the committee's my answer
stands now when you looked at these
records in the committee's offices did
you observe that money was still being
credited to a capital account under the
name of call after you allegedly
relinquished your interest I don't
recall seeing the money was still being
credited there could have been I wasn't
focusing on that we were trying to
understand what coral was all about
there were dogs and cats and alcohol
manner of line items in that account
well is it a fact that the record showed
no money even during the period that you
had you a profit interest according to
your testimony being credited to you
under your own name I don't understand
the question isn't the money being
credited to you during the 1984-85
period under the name of coral I'm not
sure I don't know well didn't you see
splits of the profits I saw a lot of
numbers that we couldn't make any sense
out of we labored for a long time trying
to make sense out of them there were
operational expenses throughout that
coral account did you find anything in
those records which indicated that money
was being credited to your capital
account no and you don't know under what
name the money was being credited to
your account by mr. Hakim in 1984 I was
told it was under an account under my
name and so that your claim is that the
first time you discovered that there was
no money that appeared on these records
being credited to you
account was when you came to our offices
again the question is too big I don't
know what you're saying
well is it your testimony that the first
time you realized that there was no
money credited to your capital account
under your name was when you saw records
in our offices I didn't see any capital
account under my name when I saw the
records in your offices that's the point
isn't it that the count you sort capital
accounts but nothing that reflected your
name I look for it and couldn't find it
do you know what happened to those
records I I don't know did you ever
discuss with mr. Hakeem what happened to
those records I've had no discussions
with mr. Hakim on the records mr. Hakeem
tell you at the time in 1984 and 85 that
he was crediting money to your account
under my name yes and so it came as a
surprise to you when you didn't see her
I was looking for it yes and did you
have a partner in this venture by the
name of coral no so you don't know who
would be getting the capital profits
that were being credited to coral do you
I don't know that those are profits
that's a capital account from which
there are a lot of operational expenses
dispersed did you you kept your own
record am I correct of of the receipts
and disbursements in this account I kept
an approximate record and I turned it
over to you and those are records that
were reviewed yesterday yes sir
and those are records that reflected
information that was being given to you
by mr. Hakim information I was giving
him and info he was giving me was there
any occasion in which Hakim turned down
your request for information during that
period no I can't think of any now you
said that you had no direct economic
interest in these accounts after August
of 85 is that correct
I said approximately at that time
yes did Hakim ever tell you that he was
leaving instructions in his will that
you would have the control over these
funds if anything happened to him yes he
did tell us what he said he said that
they thought it was prudent since he had
the sole management responsibility for
this enterprise that if something that
occurred to him that I would have to
since he had all the accounts I had no
signatory authority at all that he was
making he will I've not seen the will
inform he made a will which would give
me the necessary authority and when you
say necessary Authority you mean
authority to withdraw money from these
accounts yes and when did he tell you
that I don't remember exactly but it was
about the time the Iran initiative got
started now you testified yesterday and
today that you received no money from
either the arms sales to the Contras or
to the to Iran
am I correct I said I got my salary and
your salary was all that you got net
salary was six thousand a month my
personal money is now you remained a
partner in stt GI right yes and mr.
Hakim was your partner yes did s TT GI
the partnership that you had with mr.
Hakim received payments from Switzerland
yes and do you remember how much it
received I estimated for you that it was
over time about four or five hundred
thousand dollars and this money was
coming from the Swiss accounts this
money appears to have been coming from
those Swiss accounts that we looked at
in your committee room but my belief was
that this was a result of the line of
credit loan that we signed with CSF in
1985 so when
money was coming in in 1985 and 86 it's
your testimony that you treated it as if
it were alone mister Hakeem's companies
alone from CSF and what is CSF CSF is a
is a fiduciary company in a brokering
company in Switzerland owned by mr.
zuker it's owned by sucker I believe it
is yes and Zucker is Hakeem's
representative am i correct yes
now who arranged for these payments to
come from CSF mr. Hakim did you ever
sign any notes no yes I did a signing up
with CSF how much so did he for how much
I don't recall I'd have to look at the
documents have you paid the money back
we've been unable to pay the money back
have you had any demands in writing to
pay the money back
not as yet how long has this alleged
loan been outstanding I didn't call it
an alleged loan how long has what you
call a loan been outstanding now two
years you've been paying any interest on
it no do you know where the money's it I
think it appears that the money's came
from our accounts from Hakeem's accounts
and it appears that those money's came
from the arms sales to the countries and
Iran doesn't it not Iran no well when
you say not Iran the money is fungible
isn't it yes sir and the sources of
money and those accounts that you looked
at were from the arms sales to Calero
from arms sales to Iran and from
contributions by the countries right
right so this
for 500,000 or whatever it is came from
those sources correct I haven't been
able to audit those accounts yet but it
appears that that that that's what
happened remember mr. Hakim since you're
talking about money's being fungible
remember mr. Hakim had considerable
profit account of his own but the monies
you've seen by looking at those records
came from the accounts into which the
money was going from these arms which
may be it which might be his profit
accounts I don't know well didn't those
accounts when you looked at them start
with balances close to zero and build up
from the profits of these sales yes and
you still deny that the money that
Stanford Technology Group Stafford
technology trade group Inc was receiving
was coming from the arm sales what
contributions to the Contras I already
answered the question I don't know
I imagine we'll find out now in fact did
some of the payments come in October of
86 I don't have any documents in front
of me here so I don't remember that
I don't remember specific I represent to
you that his records showed that they
did with that refresh your recollection
I'd have to look at it and study it when
you looked at those records in our
offices weren't you interested in
finding out how much money came to your
company from the Iranian arms sales no
we were we were trying to determine
other facts now did you also get money
at Stanford Technology Group from you
Doyle ug ALL yes
now Udall was a company that was formed
to only aircraft and airstrip for the
countries am I correct yes sir
and I'm also correct that whatever money
went to Udall came from these Swiss
accounts right and the money that went
to Udall was derived therefore from the
Iranian profits or the contributions
correct correct and how much money went
from Udall to your partnership Stamford
technology trade Group Inc I think it
was fifty thousand dollars we agreed
Hakim and I that I needed to hire
another man to try to straighten out
this contra project and so as I
testified I hired
Colonel Robert Dutton starting in May of
1986 and it was our agreement
Hakeem's in mind that s ttg I would be
reimbursed from Udall for his services
and we submitted several invoices only
one of them ever got paid and what was
your feet to be at Stamford Technology
my agreement with hakeem on this was it
for a one-year period that we would
build them for up to two hundred
thousand dollars to cover the cost of
his salary and expenses travel back and
forth what was his salary 5,000 a month
60,000 per year right did you not in
addition bill them for the out-of-pocket
expenses such as his travel I think on
one invoice we did bill and that's it
was to be part of the $200,000 look at
exhibit 16 in the book before you sure
[Applause]
hey that's on Anita
okay I have it
now it indicates that this is an invoice
state of June 26 1986 right is that an
invoice that you approved yes sir
and it was for $50,000 yes plus some
expenses you see noted here and the
$50,000 was to cover mr. Dutton salary
that's right and overhead in the office
and so on well stamp the technology
trade group was in business before you
got into this right right and you're
also receiving these substantial loans
at that time right right now in addition
to the $50,000 did you build for as
little as forty as twenty five dollars
and five cents for a lunch meeting these
were the these were the bills he
submitted so that you were going for
your disbursements as well as this thing
yes and wasn't it a fact that there was
a markup for profit and what you were
billing you dork I don't think so but we
build just like lawyers did we build for
us for a fee well would it shock you to
learn that lawyers bill for profit
hardly and would that therefore refresh
your recollection that you also build
for profit possibly but mr. Liman I
agreed with mr. Hakim defense about two
hundred thousand dollars to cover the
costs of this additional burden and that
was the the route we were traveling and
we by the way submitted another invoice
which we don't have here but it was
never paid mr. seacord when you say you
agreed with Hakim weren't you directing
the payments out of these Swiss accounts
in effect and so you directed that this
we pay to stamp a Technology Group
correct yes we need to also clean the
entity run the company in depth and the
cover overhead and you also will talk
more about overhead in a moment you also
directed that the money be given to you
to all in the first place right now did
you also receive other payments from
from a through the Swiss accounts during
this period other payments square into
Stanford technology either stamp the
technology or to yourself oh not to me
well would you look at exhibit 24
which is a transfer order from the
Republic National Bank dated October 1
85 for a check to be issued to Richard
the Secord stamping technology in the
amount yes let me get to get the amount
down twenty nine thousand five hundred
seventy eight dollars and was that also
money that was derived from these funds
and the Swiss accounts yes it says it
came from CSF investments and what was
that for this was part of our line of
credit loan are we looking at the same
document
I'm looking at one that has $52,000 okay
it's the next page the one of them is
450 2500 that's all I'm looking at okay
that's - Richard Lee Secord Stanford
Technology trading group energy and that
money came out of CSF that's that's what
the document says and that money was
money that you have generated through
long sales for CSF correct possibly and
is it also true if you look at when you
say possibly we're generating money from
things other than that from out in you
know it's possible this came from CSF as
I believed it was coming if you look at
the next documents that's an issuance of
a check to green 429 AF green for twenty
nine thousand five seventy eight which
is not I should say your lawyer did you
direct that payment
no no what it was for I have no idea now
I don't think it's related to us did you
also direct payments to ace mister God's
company yes sir
and did you in directing the payments to
ace provide for a profit mark up for mr.
god of over fifty percent profit of over
fifty percent I don't believe so but he
was expected to make a reasonable profit
it was a commercial enterprise did you
determine what that profit would be no
but I tried to monitor it and if you
would you look at exhibit 15
[Applause]
me I read it briefly I haven't seen this
for a long time
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
this is mr. Dutton's analysis which I
asked him to undertake of the ACE
operation mr. did mr. Dutton report to
you that mr. GAD was getting a profit of
some 58% of 57.6% this was his estimate
in to money in two different months now
these monies also were coming from the
fund generated by the Iranian arms sales
contributions and the original clear of
sales correct yes
now tell us what defects freeboard FX
Switzerland is I'm not sure I speculated
based on my recall of some conversations
which I had had with mr. Hakim I
speculated to your staff that this was a
cover mechanism that he had built into
the into the accounts would you explain
what you mean by that it it appears that
in managing the accounts mr. Hakim had
set up one or more companies through
which he transferred monies for the
purpose of disguise disguising the
source of the monies who is he trying to
disguise the money from you know all the
arms dealers well did the arms dealers
have something which the United States
government did not access to his Swiss
records no but he didn't want them to be
aware of the banks from which the monies
were flowing in every case he was trying
to confuse he was trying to confuse the
situation and he did well
to the own defect company in Portugal I
think so
oh no in Portugal no sir
I thought you meant the freeboard shell
company so he took a name deaf X which
was the name of the Portuguese arms
company and put that on the name of one
of the bank accounts into which this
money was flowing
your testimony as you sit here today is
other than what Hakeem has testified to
he has never told you we still have the
money that's what you telling us he has
told me repeatedly that we still have
the money okay but I but he didn't
quantify it for me did you ask him when
he told you we still have the money what
are you going to do with it
I asked him what he's going to do with
it
it was frozen and do you have any deal
with mr. Hakim for sharing in that money
when it's unfrozen no mr. Liman I do not
so far as you know this money is his to
do with as he wishes
if it is unfroze it's a difficult
question I'm not I'm not a lawyer but
I've testified to you that the the money
is the enterprise's money these
enterprises were set up at my direction
and under my overall supervision I've
told you that there are many bills
outstanding in these bills are worrisome
to me I don't know how much money's
going to be left once they're all paid
off well and we'll cross that bridge at
that time what is the enterprise called
I called the enterprise that the
enterprise is the group of of companies
that mr. Hakim formed to manage the
contra and the Iranian project is the
enterprise what Ollie north refers to as
project democracy if he referred to my
enterprises project democracy he never
did so to me who controls the enterprise
I exercised overall control including of
the bank money but not the bank money as
it was not under my control was under
mr. Hakeem's control I entrusted to him
the financial management of this network
now
the two purposes of the enterprise were
contra assistance and the Iranian arms
deals yes sir and no other purposes
there were no other purposes intended
now
did you testify incidentally that you
have no connection with Hakeem's company
Stamford technology in California I have
no current connection he had me listed
as a member of the Board of Directors a
couple years ago but that's been dropped
and he listened he added you to the
Board of Directors in 1985 I think was
84 and he added you to the Board of
Directors at the time you were doing
these arms sales no before way before
well if I were to show you exhibit 18
would that refresh your recollection
that you were added to the Board of
Directors on June 4 1985 that's what it
says I've never seen that before
and that was at the time that you were
producing the business from Calero yes
but I think this simply confirmed an
earlier agreement can you tell me
whether there were any other sources of
revenue for your business with mr. Hakim
other than the on sale to the Contras
the Iranian arms sales and the
contributions you were receiving for the
Contras yes we had income from from
different clients that we represented
and were those still continuing
operations in 1985 they were but because
of neglect
we lost our major client now
in 1986 you testified you were asked to
serve as the commercial cutout yes sir
in the Iranian deal
am I correct yes sir and your testimony
has consistently been that you were
doing that for your country and not for
profit correct that's right and you said
that the purpose of your playing this
role was to conceal the United States
involvement from Iran correct that was
one of the purposes yes didn't you
testify yesterday that that was what the
purpose was I said that the two
countries could not deal with one
another directly it was therefore
decided to mirror more more or less the
Israeli the previous Israeli operation I
didn't make that decision mr. Liman you
know a bunch of lawyers made that
decision I wasn't the interior decorator
of that decision the United States
government could have performed that
operation in an infinite number of ways
they chose to do it the way they chose
to do it for the reasons they had mr.
seacord do you would call yesterday at
page 36 being asked these questions by
mr. Nields can I see the page I don't
have it well we'll give you the
transcript thank you
thirty-six
such 754 if you look at it I'm gonna
read it
750 I'll stop what page are you reading
from page 36
page 36 on our blank page 36 you got one
line on 36 line up 37 got a 37 right
after 36 yeah I'm a 35 a 35 which what
which would you like us to look at well
I'd like you to look at 36 if we can
give you 120
perhaps you can read this no have it now
yeah just indulge us one
now mr. seacord yes sir you testified
with some precision yesterday about
events going back over a year or two I'm
asking you now about something that took
place yesterday
will you ask these questions and did you
give these answers yes sir at launch
7:50 mr. Nields I think you indicated
that neither Israel nor the United
States could sell directly to Iran I
think you said that wasn't a legal
problem it was some other kind of
problem precisely from whom was this
plan designed to keep the fact that the
United States would be selling to Iran
and mr. seacord from Hawaii mr. Nields
let me mr. seacord who was involved in
the planning mr. Nields no let me
reframe it I take it both the United
States and officials in Iran knew that
the United States was selling arms to
Iran mr. seacord right question okay the
commercial cut out was designed in order
to conceal that fact answer yes question
from home answer from the Iranians
question anyone else answer nor question
how about the Congress answer if that
was intended it was never discussed in
my presence I don't think that was their
plan I think that they were interested
in concealing it from Iran only when you
ask those questions and did you give
those answers yes and were they true
well they were true I could expand on
that if you want well I'll have some
questions for you that will give you
that opportunity
shoot is it a fact that the weapons that
were delivered to Iran were u.s. weapons
yes is it a fact that mr. North Colonel
North dealt directly with the Iranian
official after our we were able to
arrange it yes is it a fact that mr.
MacFarland dealt directly with the
Iranian official in terror and yes
secretly was mr. McFarlane posing as a
representative from Timbuktu or as a
representative of the United States
obviously from the United States did you
carry over a Bible to the Iranians
inscribed by the President to the United
States they did yes and you were aware
of it yes and the president of the
United States didn't discuss who he was
that even though so it's still your
testimony that the purpose of putting
you in as an intermediary was to conceal
the fact that the United States was
dealing with Iran from the Iranians sure
and it makes sense the Iranians had to
be able to say that they were not
dealing with the Great Satan directly
they're dealing with a company they're
dealing dealing through Europe did Lake
ever send a single invoice to the
Iranians
no did it ever issue a single piece of
paper to the Iranians saying you're
buying these from Lake
mr. Niels and mr. excuse me sir mr.
Liman there's there's no question that
the covert operation was designed to be
concealed from Congress there's no
question of that I mean they didn't they
chose not to notify the Congress but
that wasn't my decision
it wasn't my fight my decision at all I
wasn't involved in that decision isn't
it a fact that Blake's identity was the
thing that was concealed here
from the Iranians I don't follow you
well that you never gave out Todd saying
wake to the rain oh yes we did you never
gave him the name of the array of lake
as the place to send it then you just
give him a bank account no no we gave
him lake did you give him invoices no
but we sure gave him the name of the
account they knew they were dealing with
Lake and they knew that Lake was being
the intermediary for the United States
government those who were in the know
didn't knew it yes is it a fact that the
reason that Lake was employed was to
generate these mock-ups that could be
used for the country's wrong I suggest
you ask the designers well let's talk
about one of the designers would you
look at exhibit 10
which is a memorandum prepared by mist
by Colonel Noah family this files
[Applause]
we don't have a number 10 mr. Lyman we
don't have an exhibit number 10 we do
not have it sir are you sure
[Applause]
I don't know they look at
I have the document in a particular part
of the document want you want me to look
at you've seen parts of this printed in
the tower report am i correct yes this
is the famous diversion memo as it's
been called I believe so if you look at
page 5 and 75219
okay reads the residual funds from this
transaction are allocated as follows two
million dollars will be used to purchase
replacement tolls for the original 508
sold by Israel to Iran for the release
of Benjamin Weir this is the only way
that we have found to meet our
commitment to replenish these stocks
Riyadh yes sir
and the second paragraph 12 million
dollars will be used to purchase
critically needed supplies for the
Nicaraguan Democratic resistance forces
this material is essential to cover
shortages and resistance inventories
resulting from their current offensive
and sandanista counter-attacks and to
bridge the period between now and when
Congress and when congressionally
approved lethal assistance beyond the 25
million dollars in defense of arms can
be delivered you read that yep did you
tell Oliver North that 12 million
dollars from the made transaction was
going to be used for the Contras no sir
your view that Oliver North just made
that up
yes sir it's your position mr. seacord
and that Oliver North was prepared to
let you generate whatever profits you
could
to use as you saw fit it's my position
that he knew that I was generating money
to keep the enterprise going he well he
well knew at least in a macro sense what
the numbers were and he had trust in me
and my men and he felt that we were
doing the right thing I don't think you
answered the question is it your
position that Oliver North was prepared
to let you spend whatever the profit was
as you saw fit yes and that you never
told him before you were brought into
this transaction as a quote commercial
cutout and the quote that the money
would be dedicated for the countries no
definitely not he had an expectation I
think he had a legitimate expectation
that we would support the Contras to the
extent that we could after all this
airlift project was mine I conceived of
it others were operating it but I
conceived of it wanted it to function
correctly it had to have money
it was always short of money you have
documents that prove that we sent the
money that we thought that we could
spare from the Iranian initiative did
you tell him that that's what you would
do before you were written in to this
transaction as the commercial cut out it
was never discussed before I was written
into this transaction at the time you
entered into the transaction were you
aware that there was a difference
between the price that the arms could be
purchased from the United States at
under the Economy Act and the price that
you could get from Iran I was not
initially aware of that but I became
aware of it were you not aware of that
in January before the January 17 finding
was signed that the Iranians were
prepared to
10,000 at toe I don't recall whether I
was informed of that at that time or not
I don't think so I'll show you a
document later those I think will
refresh your recollection you remember
being told at some point that that's
what they were prepared to bet that's
where Gurbani fire had offered during
his visit here I didn't talk to her
about a fire when he was here in January
but you were told that he had been
north-north told me at some point that
he was proposing to sell the missiles
for ten thousand five hundred each and
you knew that the economy rate was lower
no I didn't they don't the first that I
heard of the economy rate was when I was
in the meeting in the sit room with the
CIA lawyers and that was when you were
looking over the finding yes and you
understood that there was going to be a
substantial surplus did you not at that
time when I was looking over the finding
yes no when did you first realize that
there was going to be a big market after
we found out what the missiles cost and
you went in after I computed and it was
took quite a while what the probable
expenses would be well didn't you find
out that the missiles would cost thirty
five hundred dollars roughly not during
that meeting it was later later in
January yes
so by sometime in the end of January you
knew that the Iranians were going to pay
ten thousand a missile and that you
would be paying something around thirty
five hundred right mr. Lyman we could
have sold those missiles at par and the
government could have financed my
operation they chose not to do it that
way well your position yesterday was
that your markup was to cover overhead
that's right in operating expenses and
your view is it your view that you
needed sixty five hundred dollars a
missile to cover overhead
it was my view that we needed to accept
the offer made by mr. gorban afar
because we had a very uncertain very
broad scoped covert operation to execute
the enterprise needed money the
enterprise needed money mr. Lyman you
wouldn't have done it without generating
money you would have been foolish to do
so
been irresponsible not to put money into
those accounts the US government did not
give me money to run this complex
operation I wish they had is it your
position that Gabbana far would not have
accepted a price less than ten he would
gladly have accepted a price less so you
said 210 when you knew he was willing to
pay it right and at the time you were
talking about the sale of 4,000 toes is
that correct
to Iran the question was there were to
be 4,000 toes sold to Iran that was the
initial plan yes and do you have a piece
of paper there that you can do some
arithmetic on 4,000 toes at 10,000 each
would be 40 million 40 million dollars
and at $3,600 each 4,000 toes would be
something like 14 million I don't know
well it's an interesting exercise as
hypothetical it never was enacted that's
what you were talking about at that time
and we also sold toes at a lower price
later on as the situation adjusted in
January you were talking about 4000 toes
that 10,000 each one that's absolutely
correct and you never did even any
mental arithmetic that showed you that
you had a $26,000 growth twenty-six
million dollar gross profit no because
we were going to step at a time we
didn't know if this operation was going
to be terminated and it was your view
that you needed 26 million dollars for
overhead I answered the question and you
said you were going a step at a time
because she thought the enterprise might
be terminated we were not sure it was a
one step at a time what would happen to
the 26 million dollars if they
terminated the venture the 26 million is
hypothetical never occurred mr. Lyman it
wasn't hypothetical when you were
negotiating with the Iranians we didn't
say that we didn't negotiate with
Gurbani fire for 4000 missiles we
negotiated for 1000 missiles were you
not told that the deal was 4000 missiles
we amongst ourselves in the American
side talked about an authorization that
had been given by the president for up
to 4000 missiles
did you not discuss that number with
cabana for 4000 missiles yes I don't
think so now did you did you have a
discussion at some point where you were
going to sell a thousand missiles is the
first step
yes sir and you went over that with mr.
Nields yesterday yes correct yes sir and
when you did that you ended up selling
the missiles for 10 million
you said you paid three million seven
that left a gross profit of six point
three you ended up with transportation
expenses of eight hundred and fifty
thousand that left you a surplus of five
point four and you set aside about eight
hundred thousand for the Israelis which
left four point six million is that
correct the numbers that I testified to
are as follows ten million in three
point seven the CIA approximately eight
hundred and fifty thousand two the
expenses of transportation etc eight
hundred and twenty-two thousand reserved
for the Israeli tow procurement what is
that comfortable and two million dollars
set aside for insurance that's that is a
total of seven point four if you don't
want to credit the two million you call
it five point four and five point four
means that there was four point six
million at the bottom line there's four
six four point six two million of it in
a CD to cover halt insurance well the
two million dollars in CDs to cover
insurance is what we talked about before
when you return turn the plane you kept
the money but the operation continued so
we had to have it but each time that you
were selling arms you were charging a
sufficient markup to cover the cost of
the plane warranty we still had that
commitment and went up and mr. Lyman
this is not a hard concept to understand
I don't understand why you keep heckling
me on this point it's not a hard concept
to understand if it's too hard for you
to understand I'm sorry I've answered
the question and your position is that
the 4.6 million dollars you had to keep
in my position
as I stated it not as use data so stop
trying to change my story and move my
story around the facts are the facts and
the facts are that at the end of this
transaction when you return the plane
yet 4.6 million left
isn't that the fact that yes fine get
off of it you know that's fine yes I'll
accept your construction go ahead please
is it the fact I'm not interested in a
construction I said we had 4.6 left I
tried to explain to you that we had two
million in a CD you don't want to credit
that so don't credit it I do see
something that you can cash mr. chairman
if I may I would object to the line of
questioning on the grounds that it's now
getting to be just purely argumentative
it is harassment
mr. seacord has been over this and over
this I think to a point of complete and
full explanation and I do not think that
that any progress significant progress
in finding facts or discussing policy is
occurring here anymore I think there's
an attempt to move mr. seacord
to a pre-arranged assessment that mr.
Lyman has of this operation and I think
that all that the general can do he will
of course be obedient to your ruling he
will continue to answer these questions
if he must but I think he has answered
them over and over again I would request
as his counsel that the interrogation
move on to another subject please your
objections have been noted sir and I'm
certain you realize that it is our
responsibility to gather all the
evidence available and present to the
people of the United States picture
which would be as clear as possible it
is the view of the chair at this moment
that
to council should proceed as he has if
at some late a moment you feel that has
gone too far
please advise the chair mr. Lyman please
proceed with the chair indulge me a
moment to speak with my client please do
thank you sir
did you understand that a CD was
something that you could cash and spend
yes sir and you have do you have exhibit
11 yes I don't know what exhibits they
gave you
[Applause]
you not having the
in the packet
can I see the table of contents
[Music]
can you read
[Music]
I have the document but I've not seen it
before you read part of it in the travel
report I may have I'm trying to read
through it now
[Music]
okay all right
this is a proc note from Colonel North
sent as a response to a may 1686 snub
and you recall that that was the period
when you were receiving money for the
hawk missile parts transaction I don't
recall the exact dates but it's
approximately that day yes and do you
recall mr. seacord that yesterday you
testified that your profit on that
transaction was 8.3 million you put
another two million aside in a CD making
four million in CDs so after you put the
two million aside in the CD you had
about 6.3 left
correct that's a correct and would you
look at Colonel north prof mode you
should be aware that the resistance
support organization now has more than
six million dollars available for
immediate disbursement do you see that
yes did you tell Colonel North that the
six million dollars in excess of the CDs
was available to be dispersed for the
Contra movement no sir
do you think he just made this up - no
he knew what the numbers were the
approximate numbers did he ask you
whether you were prepared to commit that
for the Contra movement no he knew that
of that amount couldn't be sent to the
Contras we would have not had an
operation so that the statement that
this six million is available for the
Contras actually available for immediate
a disbursement if it refers to your
enterprise is not true that's what your
testimony is that's my testimony
now
you testified yesterday in fact
yesterday you called the money that was
in the that the 14 million dollars that
was generated in the venture as surplus
you recall that yes sir was there a
reason that you don't like to use the
term profit yes because people have been
calling me profiteers so I thought
perhaps a change in terms might improve
the accuracy and you have testified
before that you resented very much the
notion of being accused of profiteering
yes sir
and you do isn't that I do indeed now is
it a fact that out of the proceeds of
the Iranian arms sale you bought a ship
called the areia yes sir and that ship
was to be used for a covert mission
assigned to you by Colonel North correct
and that covert mission had nothing to
do with Iran or the Contras that's
correct and you paid about three hundred
and fifty thousand dollars for that
correct now I'd like you to look at the
exhibit that mr. Nields directed you to
and his examination exhibit three and
it's number 17 of exhibit three we don't
have a number three
you had that originally you do not keep
the exhibits they took them out of our
book okay maybe we have a full set now
you got a 1 a 2 and a 4 no three we
don't have a full set
[Applause]
three
now that's the message that you sent to
Colonel North about chartering diarrhea
not number three its exhibit three
number 17 there are exhibit three
consists of your messages sent on the
machine and it has a whole number of
pages okay exhibit three number 17 page
17 I have it see it begins Olmsted here
in the office yes sir
now Olmsted was a man you employ he was
a volunteer volunteer
are you suggesting he didn't get any
money other he got expenses only he got
nope no salary or compensation and was
he a friend of Colonel North's yes sir
and it was Colonel North who introduced
you at Olmsted yes sir and Olmsted is
the man who assisted you in buying the
airstrip in Costa Rica yes sir and he
was also the person who assisted you in
buying this ship theoria yes and he
operated at all times under this code
name yes
now did you tell Olmsted that he should
try to charter this ship which you had
paid about three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars for for a million - for
six months but that was the never week
night and finally came to you as you see
in my message and is the factor that you
estimated that your rough expenses were
fifty thousand dollars a month that was
a rough yes yes and so for six months
that would be three hundred thousand
dollars yes and
you would be getting a gross markup of a
million to a million of 900,000
difference between 300 and a million to
using that arithmetic you're correct and
you also said that one of the reasons
that you needed to have a markup was
that the mission was dangerous and the
ship might not come back yes sir do you
know where that ship was going and and
second yes I know where it's going then
you would agree with me well is it your
suggestion that the captain was prepared
to go on a suicide mission it's my
suggestion that the captain was very
brave and was willing to take a mission
which involved considerable hazard but
you were prepared to set aside what the
cost of the vessel was which was 375
right and if the vessel came back you'd
have the 375 right right then you said
something about the fact that you needed
some money in the event that the crew
lost their lives you needed to pay death
benefits is that correct yes and we
didn't know all the cost this was the
first cut we are not shipping people I'm
not a naval officer I don't know
anything about running ships so we're
just taking a wild guess but when you
took the wild guess did you make sure
that you took a wild guess that left you
with a lot of profit left me with enough
money to do what we thought had to be
done wouldn't you do it that way mr.
Liman well I don't purport to be in the
business of philanthropy fine now
is it a fact and this is all I want from
you that when you set the charter rate
for this vessel that you were setting it
at a rate that would enable you to make
profit it appears that way
that wasn't my thinking at the time I
wasn't considering the concept of profit
if there were any profits of course it
would have gone into the enterprise it
says therefore we are asking $50,000 per
month for risk right isn't that what the
profit was for taking the risk if you
want to call a profit call a profit it
doesn't bother me
and that money would have gone into this
enterprise of course that's where the
money was coming from
now let's go to the other assets that
you bought you bought the ship of course
out of the money that came from the arms
sale right so yes that's correct so that
the CIA let's understand it the CIA sold
you the weapons for Iran at an economy
act price right right you marked it up
and ended up with a surplus correct
correct you use part of the surplus the
chart of the ship
to buy the ship right and then you
wanted to charter the ship to the CIA
for money from the CIA
in addition right right now you use part
of the money that you had in the
enterprise from the arms sales and the
contributions to buy five planes an
airstrip and some light ammunition in
Central America is that correct yes sir
and would you look at exhibit four
[Applause]
and if you look at the last page there
excuse me
look at the last page where it describes
options yes and do you recall that the
first option was to sell the planes the
airstrip for four million dollars to the
CIA that's the option listed by the
author and the author was mr. Dutton yes
and mr. Dutton is an employee of your
right and you testified that you did not
approve of this document that's correct
and that this was not your proposal
that's correct that's not the proposal
that we made to the CIA your proposal
was to give it free that's correct now
I'll read you from some testimony of mr.
Dutton referring to this document did
you show this document to general Secord
once you have prepared it answer yes
question and did he approve it answer
yes is that true
I don't recall having read all of the
document so I cannot testify that I
approve the document in whole I saw in
parts as it was being developed over
several months and it goes on to say and
the last page which is this page page 14
of the document the various options that
were presented to the CIA who had
explained those options to you answer
general Secord is that true was he
talking about
I don't understand the question is it a
fact that you are the author of the
options list no no that's not a fact is
it in fact that you are the person who
made the proposals that are listed here
to mr. Dutton to be put in this
memorandum wrong is it a fact that you
approved of these opps wrong so that if
mr. Dutton testified otherwise he'd be
wrong I don't know what he's going to
say but I can tell you that it's not my
recollection and did you authorize this
document to be given to Colonel North I
don't remember if mr. Dutton said that
this was given to Colonel north at your
request would that be wrong he would
know he was managing the project at that
point well you wouldn't know whether you
might all him that I wanted a complete
document which described the the project
itself and the assets therein I've
already testified as to why I wanted to
priced out including all the spare parts
munitions and everything so that people
could see that it was a valuable asset
read you from mr. Dutton again on page
29 of his testimony questions but the
plan was that Colonel north was to
discuss the sale of assets on behalf of
the corporation with the CIA answer that
is correct question sir in addition to
the assets there was the resupply assets
also the airstrip was among them is
that's correct answer that is correct
did you have a plan for Colonel North to
try to persuade the CIA to buy these
assets I had a plan for Colonel North to
persuade the CI to take over this
project mr. Liman you'll note that even
in mr. Dutton's paper here and a note
one it does not anticipate that there's
any profit he says that
even in his plan that these would go
back into the into the funds for
continued similar requirements under
this plan the money if you got the four
million dollars or whatever would go
back in the enterprise right right and
that's that enterprises the enterprise
that's sitting there with some eight
million dollars now right right a mentor
Pro right and you haven't once asked mr.
Hakim turned these eight million dollars
back to the United States to the United
States yes No incidentally the assets
were owned by u-dor corporation I
believe so yes and were you a signatory
for u-dor corporation no I was the
registered US Representative for you to
a corporation no and if there are
documents that are in this exhibit book
that's so state they're just mistaken to
that I am yes Richard Secord Richard
Secord
then they're mistaken where are they
let's look at them well exhibit 14
now I don't know what you have what you
don't
I've got exhibit 14 you look at one two
three four five the fifth page that
bears the number H 825 it's in French do
you speak French
no sir well it lists you as the
representative in the United States
Richard BC Court
that's news field that's news to me this
is another piece of paper that is wrong
it's irrelevant it's news to me and I
regard it as they're relevant in any
case it's irrelevant yes
you don't see my signature on that paper
well I don't see any is there is your
signature on any paper relating to the
enterprise one single piece of paper No
[Applause]
now who's mr. God who is mr. GAD I
testified yesterday how I came to go to
mr. GAD before says he work right yes
dad testified that you were trying to
sell these assets to the CIA we don't
know what anyone testified to well I'm
asking you if he if he testified that
you try to sell these to the CIA would
that be wrong
he probably that's probably what he
thought he was in constant touch with
mr. Dutton he was not in touch with me
very often very seldom at this timeframe
go for months without seeing me
and did did was he in touch with you too
mr. GAD yes infrequently after mr.
Dutton took over as I said I would go
for four months at a time without
talking with mr. GAD now speed I want to
read to you something from mr. God's
testimony during this time of late April
1986 and later did general seeker ever
tell you what he planned to do with
those aircraft meaning the ones that you
sent down to Central America if and when
Congress authorized funds for US
government funds for the Contras answer
at some point in the late spring and
early summer of 1986 I was informed that
they intended to sell those aircraft to
the Central Intelligence Agency question
who informed you of that answer general
Secord your testimony is that he's also
wrong my testimony is I did not intend
to sell them to the CIA and I told the
director that on two occasions told the
director that the first time which was
December of 1985 is it a fact that the
enterprise then consisted of one more
aircraft probably and that was one more
aircraft that had been paid for by Kors
money 60-yard thousand dollars it was
paid for by money I did not know the
source well by a donation yes sir and
you were just starting to build
yesterday that's correct yeah and what
the other hand over we were on the road
so that when you told the director that
he could take over this enterprise which
then consisted of one plane were you
surprised that he started talking about
Iran you've got it backwards I said he
started talking about Iran when I walked
through the door
in any event did you ever tell CAD that
you wanted to sell these assets to the
CIA
I don't recall telling mr. glad that I
wanted to sell the assets to the CIA
maybe he thought that's what I wanted to
do I don't remember any conversations of
that nature with mr. GAD the core
question is did we ever try to sell
these airplanes to the CIA did you did
you ask Colonel north to assist you in
selling these assets to the CIA no the
way but we talked north and I did talk
about whether the costs for these things
should be reimbursed by CI Arnott and
concluded my recollection that the best
possible option was to simply transfer
it simply let them take over and walk
away by this timeframe I wanted out of
this operation in the worst possible way
it had dragged on far too long it was
becoming very dangerous we couldn't get
support we were short of money I wanted
out of it that is the important point I
would like the committee to understand
that's what was in my mind at that time
well if you wanted out of it why didn't
you just stop and turn over all the
money to the government believe me I
thought about it more than once you
better talk to anyone about it
I talked to north about it yes did you
talk to Hakeem about it many times did
Hakim ever indicate to you any
willingness to let go of this money
you're gonna talk to him soon ask him
that question I'm not gonna presume to
put words in his mouth I was only asking
him what he said to you only asking you
what he said to you no
I'm reminded of another point that may
be of importance the US government never
asked me for the money as long as did
who in the US government knew you had
this kind of money
well Colonel North knew his boss Admiral
Poindexter knew I know I don't think the
CIA had an accurate fix on it but they
knew there was money there who do you
mean knew that you were generating these
profits the CIA knew that prices were
being charged in excess of the cost they
knew that we had to operate our
enterprise
they knew that they weren't funding it
they knew I had to fund it they know
that the money was being funneled to
your Central American operation I don't
think they did know that the money was
being used to buy a ship for another
covert activity I don't believe they did
they know that the money was being used
with some kind of operation that was
employing the DEA DEA agents I don't
know on that point they may have known
now let's talk a moment about that DEA
operation is it a fact that you were
told by Colonel North that at the very
time that he was working on the arms
sales with the hope of getting the
hostages through Iran that he was also
working on a project to ransom the
hostages I learned of that only at the
at the very last minute before going to
Israel for the McFarlane trip and you
were told that by Colonel north yes sir
and the cash that you were giving to
Colonel North was cash that was being
used by him in connection with this
ransom operation no there were several
operations over a period of time that's
that's only one operation with some of
the money being given for that purpose
yes and
did it occur to you mr. seacord
that there might be a counterproductive
aspect to be to asking Iran to get the
Hezbollah to release the hostages at the
same time that the Hezbollah was being
told that they could get some cash
for releasing them I didn't know whether
the DEA intended to deal with Hizballah
or not I was not informed of what
factions are groups that they were
dealing with and the short answer to
your question is no it did not occur to
me at the time that the that these two
ops could clash I saw them as two
separate tracks in that branch I grant
your point however that they could well
have collided you now see them now that
we've talked about it but they share a
class but at the time it didn't occur to
me and did you ever discuss this use of
the money for that ransom project with
anyone other than the good colonel mr.
Kline's mr. Hakim well mr. Kline's is
someone you brought into the venture and
mr. Hakim is someone you brought into
the van right correct right and did any
other of these gentlemen have clearances
by the way security clearances the US
government no now
and your own records show the payment to
Colonel north for this project am I
correct yes sir those those are my notes
which I gave to I don't want to have to
go through through all of that we'll
move this on now
also testified about the fact that you
had a you or your organization had a
disagreement with mr. Rodriguez do you
call that mr. hoo sir Felix Rodriguez oh
yes yes
and is it a fact that Rodriguez was
saying that these aircraft belong to the
Contras that's what was being reported
to me by my people
and is it a fact that you were taking
the position that these aircraft did not
belong to the Anthony countries but
belonged to you dog
correct and these were aircraft that
were paid for out of this
Swiss fund consisting of contributions
and money from the arms sales etc
correct and you were taking that
position with mr. Rodriguez at the very
time that mr. Danya was prepared
[Applause]
[Applause]
you also testified about the fact that
you had a viewer your organisation had a
disagreement with mr. Rodriguez do you
recall that mr. hoo sir Felix Rodriguez
oh yes yes and is it a fact that
Rodriguez was saying that these aircraft
belong to the Contras that's what was
being reported to me by my people and is
it a fact that you were taking the
position that these aircraft did not
belong to the Anthony countries but
belonged to you dog correct and these
were aircraft that were paid for her out
of this
Swiss fund consisting of contributions
and money from the arms sales etc
correct and you were taking that
position with mr. Rodriguez at the very
time that mr. Dutton was preparing these
kinds of documents for selling the
operation to the CIA right right now if
you look back at the Dutton document
[Applause]
you have a number again yeah it's
exhibit for the second option on the
last page was to lease the operational
control of the assets to the CIA for
three hundred and eleven thousand
dollars per month plus some additive
costs for the use of planes and
excessive with the alledged will see
that what page are you on the last page
up okay so yeah see that the unwritten
right
eleven thousand dollars and am I correct
sir that you computed you looked at one
two three four five pages earlier the
operating costs that your enterprise was
having down there at sixty seven
thousand a month I can't tell from a
glance I'd have to look at the figures
and analyze them well it's not the
number that appears there it's one of
many numbers it appears here is that the
total no it's not the center the hitting
non-recurring costs for commercial
operational support and then you have
others on top of it yeah a lot of other
numbers on top of it you know what they
all add up to I haven't done the
arithmetic it under a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars did you do that beats
me well 67 and 60 or 120 and then
there's six that's a hundred and
twenty-six
there's thousand 127 and 1500 128 50
3500 make it 30 130 130 two thousand
twelve thousand brings it up to about a
hundred and forty-four and then a few
other expenses there so you would
prepare proposing to lease to the CIA an
operation that was running about a
hundred and fifty thousand a month for
311 I didn't make any such proposal the
CIA and I'm not going to comment on a
document I haven't seen any part of for
a long time I have to analyze it and
again to the extent that mr. Dutton says
that that option was a proposal by you
he's just plain wrong no I'm sure that I
said to him over time that there are
many ways this could be handled they are
obviously and an intellectual exercise
you always do this this document doesn't
have any stain it's a planning planning
the drill what was really done mr. Liman
well in fact didn't oliver north try to
persuade the director to buy these
assets from you not as far as I know I
think Oliver North tried to persuade the
director to take him over that's what he
told you
yes and it's your testimony that at the
time the Hassan first plane went down
you still weren't trying to sell these
assets to the CIA no as a matter of fact
they've been in an interagency meeting
just days before and which finally I was
informed by North it had been agreed
that this was a valuable asset and that
I had to work out a way they had to work
out a way in which to take it over and
did that way include giving money to the
enterprise not in so far as I know and
north never told you that no this was
going to be a donation to the CIA as far
as you were concerned we're gonna walk
away from it that's your testimony
that's my testimony now did you have
some munitions that you paid for out of
the enterprise yes and this these were
munitions that you sold to the CIA
through an intermediary am i correct
yeah at a loss and am i correct that you
walk well when you say at a loss
they were paid for out of the donations
and out of the Iranian arms sale that is
correct you are looking at things it's
profit and loss why are you know we were
glad we were glad to transfer these
things to CI I'm simply pointing out to
you it was a very good deal for them
right and just as you were prepared to
give the CI a the aircraft that had been
bought from the fund for nothing in the
airstrip for nothing
you gave them these munitions for
nothing no we gave them the munitions
for I think the number was 1.2 million
but there were several hundred thousand
more than that invested in those
munitions and you have those numbers so
you chose to sell the munitions to the
CIA correct to be correct we sold them
to a broker that the CIA used but we
were aware that they were going to the
CIA and you also were aware that the
broker was putting a mock-up on - right
I don't have no idea what was involved
but in any event you got money at least
through the broker from the CIA for
these munitions yes and it went back
into the accounts and the money went
Snowberry accounts but the your
testimony is that on all the other
assets that you were gonna give to the
CIA free this one this one we considered
dumping also by the way that we found we
were lucky enough to find an acceptable
buyer was there any reason why you just
couldn't give them free to the CIA the
way you say you wanted to give the
aircraft and we could have done that I
suppose but we wanted to get the money
back into the accounts we needed the
money if if we hadn't got those monies
back in the accounts you would now be
saying mr. seacord you had five million
dollars diverted to the Contras rather
than 3.5 the CI was in the process of
taking over the Contras at that time so
we wanted to get the money back where it
belonged and was that one of your
motivations for selling yes your what
that you were conscious of the fact that
you could be accused of diverting money
to the contra no not that I'd be accused
of it but I would I was conscious of the
fact that we needed money in this
enterprise and we wanted to keep that
money as much as possible well at that
point how much money did you have in the
enterprise in your balance
based on the records I've reviewed now
I'd say we probably had about five
million you wanted yes we wanted to
bring it up to six million we wanted to
bring it up as much as we could and if
you could have gotten three four million
for the airfield you would have been
happy to take that to airfield in plains
right we never considered doing that but
now you pose the question it probably
would have been a better idea that was
just Dutton's idea let's move on and you
testified that among the the things that
you did at Colonel North's request was
that you approached an official of a
foreign government to ask him to make a
contribution on behalf of his government
to the Contras yes all that yes sir
who is the official you approached
you're free to determine mr. seacord are
you presently an employee of the United
States government no sir you may proceed
an asset
maybe we have a short recess
the hearing will stand in recess until 2
o'clock this afternoon
on the matter which was pending at the
time of our recess the chair rules as
follows because of the diplomatically
sensitive nature of the question
involved and until the committee's
consult further among themselves the
witness will write on a piece of paper
which we will provide the name of the
country and the official whom he
solicited and this will be held as
executive session material until the
committee's decide otherwise the
containing intention of the committee's
is to make as many of the facts public
as possible to the extent consistent
with national security interests mr.
seacord will he proceed to write the
name of the country involved and the
person is involved Thank You mr.
chairman
will you place that in the sealed
envelope
and can we do it in a way
yeah
mr. I hope the camera persons will
cooperate please otherwise we may be
forced to send you out sir it's done mr.
Chairman I thank you very much mr. mr.
Lyon mr. seacord
the official that you spoke to and whose
name you wrote is the person you spoke
to in the fall of 1984 at the request of
Lieutenant Colonel north yes sir
and Lieutenant Colonel North mentioned
at some point that this had the blessing
of mr. MacFarland
yes sir and is that the same official
you spoke to in early 1985 yes sir and
you testified that in 1986 you had a
meeting with director Casey at which
time he suggested that you look to a
another country for funding is that the
same country it is now I want to go back
to Tamiya
have you ever heard of a company called
try American Arms yes were you a partner
in that company the company was never
formed but it was discussed that we
would that I would be a partner in the
kind it was contemplated that you would
be a partner yes do you know whether
monies were transferred to try American
from the Swiss bank accounts that we
have been talking about I know that mr.
Hakim transferred some money to this
enterprise for the purpose of doing
business and the do you know sir that
the
amounts that were transferred were a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
May of 1986 and two hundred thousand in
June of 1986 no I don't think they were
I don't think the two hundred thousand
was transferred if it was I don't know
of it if I were to show you and you mark
as the next exhibits to debit advices
from one of the Swiss accounts Alban
values with that refresh recollection
these are records that are provided by
mr. hockey
got to get under our feet
nothing more I don't want you to read
the documents into the record because we
have you know wait for mr. Hakim for
that but I'm just asking you whether or
not you have a recollection now that the
total amount that was transferred was
three hundred and fifty thousand dollars
the 150,000 I was aware of I know
nothing about this second piece of paper
you'll have to ask mr. Hakim about that
now do you know sir whether the purpose
of your partnership was to invest in a
manufacturer of machine guns
manufacturer of submachine guns in a
submachine Kurtis and did that deal go
through
no was one of the purposes to have that
company sell weapons to the countries no
and with the monies that were invested
monies that came out of the Iranian and
contra arm sales I don't know I think I
thought it was part of Hakeem's profit
distribution well if you were to be a
partner what were you putting it my
management and knowledge and ability to
market there was a third partner who was
doing a similar thing and what was his
name his name is Roy and how much were
you going to be paying to acquire the
manufacture of submachine guns how much
were we going to pay yes we had not
finished the negotiation with the owner
but that was about the right amount of
money to buy the interest that we wanted
now
did you ever sign an agreement as part
of the partnership for this company no
no I did not the deal was never
consummated can you tell me what
happened to the money that was sent
well sixty thousand of it was invested
in some material and the remaining
money's minus some legal fees were
returned to st TGI stanford technology
trading group and so around eighty
thousand was returned to your company
that's a good ballpark figure and was
that treated as a loan it was a capital
investment by mr. Hakim into our company
and he made several over the years
now he testified yesterday that it was
your view that Colonel North was doing
everything he could to implement the
Boland amendment do you recall that yes
sir I want you to take a look again at
exhibit four
okay we have it would you look at the
your first page the index right after
the first page of text which says
general not army general but general yes
[Applause]
begins with due to recent changes and
operational requirements and increased
asking the benefactor company
hereinafter referred to as BC Washington
is taking more direct control of Project
Hope and its supporting elements will
you tell us what Project Hope was this
was a project that involved all aspects
of the airlift operation that I
described earlier what was BC Washington
this was just a an acronym that mr.
Dutton coined to refer to our office the
problem at the time that we were
addressing was one of lack of
effectiveness and a reorganization of in
the redirection of the effort was needed
and it says going on to the first
paragraph that begins with a BC
Washington will assume operational
control of all assets in support of
project code that is the airlift correct
okay and you tell us who the people were
who consisted of BC Washington was
primarily primarily myself and Robert
Dutton was it not also Oliver North
No
mr. Dutton has testified about this
document as follows the first pages of
it go back through the wiring diagram
which we referred to as the
reorganization plan that outlined a new
organization that was going to control
direct the operation where in general
Secord and Colonel North would
ostensibly not be part of the operation
any longer and that a new group known as
BC Washington or benefit the company
Washington would take over the
responsibilities question was that in
name only answer that was in name only
and it was in fact general Secord and
Colonel North remained exactly where
they had been in the organization etc is
that a fact yes that's a fact that
phraseology however I would like to
clarify if I may what he's talking about
is an attempt to cover my continued
participation in this operation and to
cover any contact that we had with with
Colonel North we were having
difficulties with this operation things
were not going well a lot of questions
were being asked by different people who
were critical of the operation I was as
critical as any one of it therefore we
decided to reorganize and part of that
reorganization was to cover my identity
as well as that of Colonel North Colonel
north was never a part of this little
headquarters of ours we can solder with
him as I told you every step of the way
and we gave him information and if mr.
Dutton said that Colonel north and you
were directing this operation he'd be
wrong I don't think he said that
have access to any of this testimony
we've not seen it and mr. Lyman's a
device of extracting a few lines and
reading it to us and asking us to
comment on it I think is unfair if he
wants us to review the entirety of mr.
Dutton's testimony we'll be glad to do
so but in isolation like this
I think it's an improper of quality
interrogation mr. hyneman mr. chairman
I'll restate the question did you ever
tell mr. Dutton that Oliver North was
going to continue to direct this
operation with you no I told him he was
going to continue in liaison with us he
was going to continue talking with us
dealing with us just as we always did
and you'll note that there's a KL 43
series of messages we addressed
yesterday that I think proves the
accuracy of my statement because I I
rejected some guidance which was phrased
even as an order did you consider it
implementation of the Boland Amendment
for mr. Colonel north to occupy this
role the Boland Amendment has does not
apply to private efforts and therefore I
thought that he was acting properly did
you consist considerate as an
implementation of the Boland Amendment
for Colonel North to funnel the money to
your organization private monies yes in
the bold amendment which is an anti
appropriations measure does not have
anything to do with private efforts and
did you consider it consistent with the
Boland Amendment for Colonel North to
provide you with the communications
devices this would quell 43 this was a
matter of security that was offered to
us I don't know what the reasoning for
it was did you consider it concise an
implementation of the Boland Amendment
for Colonel North to fly down to Florida
to meet with you and Calero and urge you
to start an airlift and to help open up
the southern front
he wasn't spending any appropriated
funds so I did not see anything wrong
with
and the use of the plane was not
appropriated funds incidental it was
implementation of the Boland Amendment
for him to do all of these things my
comments about implementation the Boland
amendment were general comments I
believe that these men were doing the
president's bidding and trying to do the
best job they could to live within
Boleyn I'm on the record with that
that's what I believe now you testified
that you considered what was happening
lawful and that Colonel North considered
it lawful correct yes sir is it a fact
that Colonel North told you that if the
facts ever came out about what he was
doing he would get a pardon he joked
about that in the same vein that he did
in the comment that I made yesterday
with respect to the Ayatollah well what
did you think in your own mind that he
was doing wrong that would lead him to
even think of nothing in fact nothing in
fact when that came up I laughed at him
and I said that's ridiculous but what
are you talking about that I mean this
everything we've discussed repeatedly
that no laws are being broken we're
doing everything we can to live within
the law so it's a non sequitur and he
what did he respond I don't remember
mr. Lyman I don't remember every
conversation I ever had with Oliver
North I can't tell you how often did you
speak to Oliver North in connection with
the operations that you were conducting
for the Contras once a day no less than
that less than three four times a week
on the average I'd say that's accurate
to what the wild average could you have
conducted those operations without
Oliver North we could have but it would
not been would not have been nearly as
effective
now you in your opening statement
criticize the Attorney General for going
public as quickly as he did with the
diversion my correct yes mr. Lamie
and you thought that he should have
spoken to you and gotten some of the
facts before he went public yes sir
after he went public
you became angry and decided that you
wouldn't provide him with the facts is
that fair to say I after the the
stunning announcement of the 25th of
November I consulted immediately with my
counsels I think I testified and I from
that point on relied entirely on advice
of counsel now is it a fact that you
directed your secretary to shred
documents we discussed that yesterday
well did you or didn't you direct your
secretary yes sir
did you testify yesterday that you
directed your secretary to shred
documents because you were concerned
that the press or others would get at
them right who was it who you thought
would break into your office probably
the same people who were fabricating the
telephone numbers in El Salvador I don't
know there were you know a lot of
break-ins in different places over a
periods of time associated with these
matters well so it was a concern of mine
these were documents that you had
accumulated over a period of time yeah
and they were no longer useful and over
that period of time you weren't
concerned about the break-ins to the
point that you went and shredded all
these documents no there were only a few
shredded and it was called the the
telephone and log was called to my
attention by Colonel Dutton he said boss
do we really need these old things I
said now get rid of them well didn't you
shred documents that reflected tell exes
and messages relating to the transfer of
money relating to money yes sir
the doctor telexes that I recall that we
shredded we're routine telex traffic's
the traffic with the the defects
corporation in Portugal as I testified
yesterday do you recall that the telexes
contained references to the movement of
money yes or no
I don't recall but it's entirely likely
that they did did you review the
documents before they were shredded I
glanced at them did you ask your
secretary to provide you with the files
I asked my secretary to go through the
files she's the one who selected them
and then you looked at the documents and
decided which ones would have be
shredded and which ones were not I think
I looked at the subject headings and
said that we don't need these get rid of
them and do you have any copies of the
documents that were shredded no so that
neither we nor the Attorney General have
no way of knowing what was in those
documents other than your oral testimony
I gave you thousands of documents mr.
Lyman all the relevant documents you've
given me everything other than what
you've shredded is that what you're
saying I said what I said well you
didn't give me copies of the documents
you shredded did you obviously I
couldn't can you were you not in the
security business we were in the in the
management of security business yes but
we did not expend the funds necessary to
make an office like mine secure and
that's why I knew it wasn't secure and
being in the management of the security
of management of security systems you
felt that the only way you could protect
records was to shred them if I don't
need a mr. Lyman I shred them I've
shredded tens of thousands of documents
during my career and when you don't need
these documents to get rid of them at
the time that you shredded the other
documents were there Investigations
pending relating to you no and there
were none pending at this time either
when do you say you gave the
instructions to
snipey it's my recollection my
recollection was it was in the early
November there abouts was there an
investigation at that time of southern
air the FBI I think was trying to
conduct one had you in fact telephoned
Colonel North to ask him to halt that
investment I think I'd testified to that
fact yes and was it after that
investigation commenced that you
shredded the documents I'd I don't
remember it was not a triggering event
dead no relation was are you certain
that you didn't ask mr. Napier to shred
those documents after the Attorney
General made his speech yes now you
testified incidentally did you speak to
miss Napier after she testified before
our committee about this I did not I was
a deciduous and not asking one word
about it did anyone tell you that miss
Napier had told the House Committee and
the Senate committee that she had
shredded documents at your request state
the question again please did anyone
tell you that Miss Napier had told the
House Committee and the Senate committee
that at your directions she had shredded
documents
they're attorney-client communications
involved here so I can't discuss it
are you aware sir that mr. Napier
originally testified that she shredded
the documents in December same answer
did you make any effort to persuade her
to date it back to November never talked
to her one word about it
not one word whoever was communicating
to you about what miss Napier was saying
did he communicate to you that she had
changed the story same same answer and
the same answer being attorney-client
producer mr. seacord you testified that
you saw part of the finding in the White
House Situation Room my correct that's
correct I had to read it the part that I
could read I had to read from afar they
never handed me a copy of it to read and
you read the finding that said that
third parties could be involved in the
operation with a Rand I don't remember
if I read it or if they were discussing
it that language at the time I've only
learned recently that there were changes
in that finding over time but you
testified yesterday that you were the
third party I said that I learned my
role as the third party yes was there
anything in that finding communicated to
you that authorized you to use any of
the proceeds of the sales to Iran to
assist the Contras no sir
was there anything communicated to you
about that finding that authorized you
to use any of the proceeds of the sale
to purchase a ship no sir nothing to the
contrary either was there anything in
that finding as communicated to you
that authorized you to use proceeds to
purchase radios for a Caribbean nation
no sir
was there anything communicated to you
about that finding that enabled you or
authorized you to keep proceeds in mr.
Hakeem's account no sir nothing to the
contrary you understood sir that the
purpose of the finding was to authorize
the sale by the United States to Iran of
arms through you as an intermediary as a
commercial cutout as I've testified you
did not understand that the purpose of
the finding was to provide support for
the Contras no but to enable anyone to
get rich no now you've said that one of
the reasons that you waived your
interest in the Swiss accounts was that
you wanted to return to government
someday correct and was the position
that you hoped to return to as head of
covert operations at the CIA that that
was one of my ambitions that at one time
yes now I'm not I'm not asking you about
legalities here or not I want to bring
out some facts you felt that the United
States ability to conduct covert
operations was impaired am i correct yes
sir
and you felt that you could make a
contribution in that area correct and
you felt indeed that you could do a
better job than the people who were in
charge of covert operations is that
correct
I thought so and is it fair to say then
at the request of Colonel north
and Admiral Poindexter the national
security adviser you went out and
created your own covert operation
organization for the express purpose of
carrying out the projects we've been
talking about yes and you had your own
planes for that purpose true threat true
you had your own employees for that
purpose yes sir they were in deep cover
correct not too deep but not too deep
now but you know how long it took to
find Olmstead mr. Olmstead we did a
better job on I guess but you have
people with code names yes sir the
answer that your question of course is
yes you try to keep them in cover yes
sir you had NSA communications equipment
true you had a mission for missions
correct correct
you had secret accounts correct you had
secret sources for funding of those
accounts agreed and all of the funds
were generated for you either by the
assets of the United States that were
entrusted to you such as the weapons or
by the sales to the Contras where mr.
north Colonel North introduced you to
Calero or the contributions he arranged
to go into that account is that fair
it's fair I mean I have no further
questions thank you very much mr. Lyman
may we take a two minute recess and may
I see the two members of the House and
two members of the Senate
[Music]
there we go fine that's right
join understeer
the chair now recognizes the
distinguished congressman Louis Stokes
mr. chairman the sea court during the
week of November 7th you were called to
the White House to review chronologies
and were being prepared for the Congress
and you tell us it was present that time
yes sir but I think it was the week of
November 7 17th all right yes sir
besides myself that were present Oliver
North at least one of his assistants mr.
our Colonel Rohl an NSC staff member
Howard Teicher CIA officer George cave
and I think that was all there were
there were two times that I went and
went down there and I think there was
the same card about the first time the
first time and I believe I believe it
was the same group the second time
Admiral Poindexter present knows neither
occasion no sir I see when you reviewed
the document on the first day the facts
in the chronology were correct I
believed them to be correct when you
returned the second day when you read up
to page five you determine that the
chronology had read the previous day had
been changed is that correct yes it had
been changed substantially and you said
to them this is not true and you used an
extra tip that's correct right and then
you were told that mr. McFarlane had
written that part of the document
weren't you yes sir and that's when you
said well you guys can have it or
something to sort and you walk to
that's right sir hi now your reason for
doing that was because you felt that
what was written there was not an honest
representation of the facts in that true
basically that was true and I didn't
want to be involved any further and even
when mr. Neil's yesterday asked you
about the second document on another
page and he went into certain facts that
were recited there you said that those
were a misrepresentation of the facts
yes right that's correct sir
now you knew that that chronology that
they were preparing was being prepared
for the United States Congress did you
not I knew it was being prepared for mr.
Casey to use before the United States
Congress right now do you know what mr.
North's role was in the preparation of
the chronology well he was I would say
the chief staff officer involved in the
preparations of the various drafts now
in your opening statement you described
both Admiral Poindexter and and Colonel
north as being honest and dedicated men
yes sir now the the acts you have just
testified to are not representative of
an honest man are they well sir I don't
think that mr. North made the changes he
told me that these have been written by
mr. McFarlane and so mr. McFarlane who
was the principal involved in the
information being dealt with there was
writing the text himself didn't you just
say he was the chief architect I said
that he was the chief staff officer sir
in charge of preparation of all the long
chronologies that were being put
together but his boss changed apparently
two parts of it are you aware sir that
Admiral Poindexter used the same
chronology when he briefed the House
Intelligence Committee
November 21st in the White House
Situation Room no sir and as I've told
the staff here I never knew whether this
particular piece of paper was ever used
by the director or not I didn't know
okay but if it was used the same
document was used we were briefed on
deceptive testimony working according to
my understanding of the facts that is
correct in fact what it amounts to isn't
it is a real cover-up of the facts if
they if they or he gave you that
information he may have believed it to
be correct because mr. McFarlane had
written it but it could well be a
cover-up as well if I told you that in
August of 1986 Colonel north told the
House Intelligence Committee that he had
nothing to do with raising funds for the
Contras or with activities to arm us
support them that statement would not be
true
it's it's hard for me to comment into
general away it sounds like it's
inaccurate I'd like to see the test I'd
like to see the testimony even see the
context of it if I told you that Admiral
Poindexter wrote a letter to the House
Intelligence Committee at the same time
to confirm the same story that would not
be true with exactly the same answer sir
gentlemen the opening remarks you told
us that mr. me said betrayed you
abandoned you he'd left you to defend
yourselves in light of the fact that
you've testified here that you were a
person independent of the government and
a civilian in your own enterprise tell
us what obligation the Attorney General
of the United States had to support or
defend you are your operation it was my
belief that the President of the United
States was well aware of what we were
doing
congressman Stokes and as a consequence
the Attorney General that seemed to me
had a responsibility to get more than
just an incidental dose of the facts
before going public with such a
startling story I could have at least
accorded us the opportunity within my
organization to to brace ourselves I
mean we were totally stunned and shocked
and that is why all of us felt betrayed
well was it your position sir that had
you been given the opportunity to
provide him with the facts that that
would have taken care of the matter that
no one had done anything wrong and that
the Attorney General would have
understood that there was nothing wrong
at all with this operation I don't know
what he would have understood but we
were prepared to divulge all the
information that I held and take it from
there but what I was pleading for was to
slow this thing down and let's get it on
track and and as I testified I think on
a more rational basis they could well
have continued
with a full-blown investigation I I have
no idea but didn't you tell us also
you'd want to talk to the president
United States yes sir and didn't you
tell us you even went to the trouble of
preparing a speech for the president
United States yes sir I did tell us what
you were what tell us what you did with
the speech I sent it to Admiral
Poindexter by a Colonel Norris office on
the KL 43 okay and in the speech you won
the president United States to deliver
tell us what you said the he should say
to the American people my recollection
of the main points were that he should
come up front and and tell the American
people and of course the Congress by
this time that they a covert operation
had been underway for some months that
took off what the objectives were that
point out that he was the responsible
officer in this government for the
conduct of Foreign Affairs and for
national security and that he had hard
decisions to make as Harry Truman once
said the buck stops here that he had
made some decisions there had been some
successes and great disappointments to
describe briefly some of the facts not
all the facts and then to point out that
we were going to continue to try to
establish relations with Iran and to get
our hostages back it's my recollection
is that as the thrust of the short
speech which I wrote is it your opinion
that the president has not done that
well he didn't he didn't do that at that
time the story has come out in bits and
pieces over time my point though at the
time was it seemed to me that a a strong
and firm stand by the president would be
the best defense that we had it was
obvious our gonna be great criticism of
this operation do you think that would
have stopped that there'd been no
further investigation no I think the
Congress would have done some inquiries
but I doubt that we'd have the spectacle
of an independent council at this time
well in light of the fact that within
the last 10 days two people have pled
guilty to to criminal activity in
conjunction with the Contras wouldn't
that suggest something to you other than
what you're saying here it was not
related to us at all and I don't even
know those people never met them sir I
didn't know that at the time well his
lake resources ain't your your account
yes sir are you aware of the fact that
both Channel and Miller funneled money
into Lake resources account I was not
aware of their names I was aware of the
ibc name and another company name well
just as a final point on this this
particular point could the Attorney
General in any way betray you if you
were involved in a private operation I
believe so sir as I stated because we
were in support of a US government
covert operation he did not have the
facts and he rushed to judgment
the Secord you've told us is a private
citizen you were in charge of the
commercial cut out use in Iran operation
the government sold you the missiles or
two spare parts and then you sold them
to Iran once they were sold to you they
were no longer the property of the
United States government is that correct
that's correct
are you also saying to us that at that
point the US government no longer had
the the ability to be able to order you
to conduct this covert operation in any
way they wanted conducted well I think
they had great faith that I would follow
the directions that were given and and I
did of course well if we accept this
version aren't we in effect accepting
the fact that that the United States
government contracted out its foreign
policy to you subject to you carrying
out their best wishes I don't think they
viewed it that way sir
I think that they viewed me as a
logistics and commercial logistics
operator and commercial go-between and
certainly didn't view me as being a
foreign policy and negotiator or
anything like that few moments ago are
you asked by mr. Lyman about your
operation which to a large degree
parallels the CIA operation that is
there reserved for contingencies you
operated your own fund you bought ships
airplanes things of that sort that
obviously was for the purpose of
circumventing the Boland Amendment is
that correct I didn't see it that way
well under the Boland Amendment all
agencies all individuals in our
government were prohibited from
utilizing any appropriated funds for use
of the Contras you understood that yes
sir under your operation private funds
non-appropriated funds could be used for
any purpose you saw fit and that
included for the use of the Contras well
I felt a responsibility I knew why the
funds were donated and I felt a
responsibility to make sure they got to
the contour projects and they did
doesn't it look to you like we have two
governments as one government run by the
United States which mr. Reagan has had
of where you cannot utilize appropriated
funds for the purposes we've already
enunciated in this other government run
by you that you can you can utilize
these funds for whatever purpose you
deem necessary though they be contrary
they use for which appropriated funds
can be put I'm not sure what question
put what answer your you're looking for
well I guess I understand what you're
saying I'm I didn't see it that way you
know I didn't see it that way the
president has
certain rights in the foreign policy
area I never saw myself as as being a
foreign policy operative I believe that
the funds that we had were private funds
and could be sent to the contra project
which project we believe deeply in and
we did that is it your view having been
a general having performed in government
as you has if this fits within the
constitutional framework of our
government I did sir
you saw nothing wrong with this
operation I did not see anything wrong
with it then did Colonel North salary
come from appropriated funds I'm sure it
did
how about the salaries of ambassador
Tam's likewise sir how about Colonel
Steele of course all from all US
government appropriated funds how about
the airplane pilots who flew mr. north
around the world with various meetings
he he had with you and others to the
extent they were government pilots of
course they were paid the same way well
then how do you square this fact away
with the fact that you say no
appropriated funds were used in any
manner in conjunction with your
operation it had never even occurred to
me that someone would construe normal
governmental salaries as as being
attached by bowline well when when the
Boland amendment passed on the floor of
the house of the author of the amendment
mr. Boland stated on the floor that it
would include salaries were you aware
that no I didn't have the legislative
history sir
I can tell you sir that I was aware that
Bolan was a legislative compromise I can
tell you that I've heard from a
distinguished council the chief counsel
for the Senate committee that Boland is
a piece of Swiss cheese that Boland is
an act which if you had that the IQ of a
genius
you could not trace as meanderings so I
think that there's considerable
confusion and misunderstanding about the
intentions of old well this morning when
you testified under examination by mr.
Lyman
you recall your statement to him that
the purpose of this operation was to get
around Congress
I don't recall the context in there
there were so many questions I'm not
sure exactly which question you're
referring to
well that one of the purposes of our
contra project was to get around
Congress earlier this morning and
provided one of his questions when he
talked about the operation and the
purpose for what you fit into the
operations are cut out person yes sir
you stated to him I believe you can
correct me if I'm wrong that that the
purpose of that setup was to get around
Congress if I if I said that I misspoke
I don't recall that context at all
the purpose of the operation was to
conduct a project which was legal under
Bowen as far as we could see for men who
worked for you such as Dutton and GAD
what did you tell them about your
operations you tell them that the United
States government was behind your
operation no and they knew they knew
that government was not they knew it was
private they knew the government was not
behind they knew the government could
not support us materially because of
Bowland did you get some help from
government officials yes sir and I
testified to the kind of help we got you
told us about ambassador Sam's and what
he did for you yes sir I tell us again
what he did for you I never spoke I've
never spoken directly to ambassador tam
so my information comes to me through
people who talked with him and he gave
us guidance and he was a moral supporter
of our plan to construct to acquire and
construct the airfield in Costa Rica and
I'm sure that he was also a supporter of
our efforts to supply the southern
troops now you've also told us that a
senior CIA field officer in Costa Rica
provided valuable intelligence and
communication support for you to me yes
sir he did it was a valuable support it
was we we could not have done without it
how about the senior CIA field office in
Honduras no but that was different as I
testified yesterday he was able to or
one of his people was able to discuss
certain problems we had a coordination
with the fdn people the bottom line is
that even though you represented that
the US government could not be involved
in this operation the fact is the US
government officials were involved worth
it but they were but I don't believe
they were spending materially at least
appropriated funds well these these
officers were talking about a salaried
employees the United States government I
think yes sir
and without their aid and assistance you
could not have accomplished this mission
is that we their aid and assistance was
invaluable it would been very difficult
to accomplish the mission thank you
thank you miss Jeremy
many when our turn to later it's not a
born
the Chairman had indicated there'd be
alternating between House and Senate
members and Senator Bourne will thank us
Thank You mr. chairman mr. seacord I've
listened with great interest as you
describe some of your own feelings about
the foreign policy of United States as
you have indicated your perceptions
about what is going on in the Central
America and also with interest as you
made some of the decisions in the
process of this attempt to open new
communications with those in Iran I
gather that you became disillusioned
along the way with mr. Gore Bonny far as
the main channel into Iran is that
correct yes senator and what did you do
about it after you became disillusioned
and you felt that simply was not going
to work out to open communications with
Iran through mr. Giovanni Farr and his
associates well briefly sir shortly
after the failed mission to Tehran which
took place the end of May 1986 I
discussed this issue with mr. Hakim and
I also notified Colonel North that we
were going to actively search for a
second channel to the elements of the
Iranian government we wanted to deal
with this had been decided as a goal as
I understood it at a meeting two months
before but I didn't see any progress
being made so you made the decision and
you took the action really you took the
leadership and opening the second
channel is that correct that is correct
sir did you discuss this with the
Secretary of State no sir only with
Colonel North only with Colonel North
not with a second but really you took
the action yourself did you not
that's that's correct you think it's
strange for a private citizen did you
hold any position with the government at
this time no social position no siree
it's strange for a private citizen to be
taking an action of such importance for
the foreign policy of the United States
as purporting to represent this country
and the opening of communications with
an element in the government of a
foreign power
it's very strange sir and I looked for
as hard as I could a better channel the
one we had was was corrupt and when I
found what I thought was the right
channel I turned this over to the
government and they vetted it and
eventually agreed with us was this
discussed with the president the United
States as to whether or not a second
channel should be open I believe it was
but she really took the action yourself
before any discussion with the president
of the Secretary of State or anyone else
no sir I didn't open the second channel
I was searching for it's a second
channel so you see nothing strange at
all the terms the way that we make
foreign policy in this country for a
person who's purely a private citizen
with no official government capacity to
be making the kinds of decisions and
deciding about the identity of people
within the government some of whom had
relationships to very high government
officials and the government of Iran
this is a very revolutionary change
yourself talked about one meeting being
the first meeting between any American
officials and Iranian officials in a
long time you were you don't see
anything strange about you as a private
citizen negotiating in this way I think
it's a very strange very unusual you
think it is appropriate we're in the
bicentennial year of the Constitution
you think it's appropriate that
important foreign policy decisions of
this country should be made by mr.
Richard Secord private citizen instead
of by the Congress of the United States
Secretary of State and the President of
the United States looking back at it I
think that you can make that criticism
very easily but I must tell you sir that
I was doing the best I could under the
circumstances and I thought I was
carrying out the president's policy and
I was not trying to usurp anybody's
authority I and I did not when I found
this second channel I turned it over to
the United States for their vetting and
then in other words I was trying to do a
service to try to find a channel there's
one meeting was there not with the
second channel in which the discussion
was undertaken about the creation of an
informal communications panel three from
Iran and three from the United States is
that correct yes but that was in the
White House
were you there I was there who else was
present on the American side colonel
north and george cave from CIA the three
of you were there yes sir and when it
came time to name the three Americans
who were going to represent the United
States and the interests of this country
on this informal panel who were the
three people that were named the North
meeting during the course of that
meeting north named him to the second
channel people as I recall he said that
the only valid communication these
people are concerned about valid
communications and who they were dealing
with they don't they could should
consider that the only valid
communication would be one they received
from him from
mr. Kaber from me that's my recollection
and so this group was appointed I
understand that on the Iranian side they
named some fairly high-ranking people
that were to have communication they had
a couple of fairly high-ranking people
but the group never met the group never
met but the the appointments were
announced in this negotiating session
the president United States signed in an
order appointing Colonel north yourself
as a private citizen mr. cave to
represent officially the government of
United States and these talk I didn't
see that I was representing the United
States he simply said that they should
because they knew us that they shouldn't
sign any such order no sir the president
did not there was the president aware to
your knowledge of such appointments
being made I was told that mr.
Poindexter and the president were being
completely informed of all substantive
matters well do you know whether or not
the president of United States knew
specifically about the appointment of
these three individuals to represent our
country and opening this channel of
communication with the three that were
named on the array nights I do not know
and I do not agree that there were three
people named to represent the United
States well you can construe it any way
you want I guess we can all interpret it
now you as I understand that were asked
to stop the Central American Air Lift at
a certain point there were problems in
El Salvador's you went into the first
day of testimony is that correct that we
were asked to harassed to stop using the
Salvadorian a base of operations you
were asked to temporarily suspend the
airlift operations I believe yes so much
yes they were met there were messages on
that messages on that from whom did
those messages come they come from
Colonel or I believe that they
originated with him but they came from
his assistant all right so they came
from people to National Security Council
yes sir Colonel Arthur's assistant yes
sir and I as I understand you rejected
that request and felt very strongly that
would be wrong for you to give up that
base of operations at that time that's
correct
so you continued that I thought that
they were misinformed and the problem
was was misinformed
so in other words again we have mr.
Richard Secord private citizen
substituting his own personal judgment
and the conduct of an operation for the
aid of people that we were trying to
help in this country in fact in
coordination with the National Security
Council rejecting the request from the
National Security Council because mr.
Richard Secord private citizen no
appointment from the president felt that
was the wrong thing to do is that
correct that's correct and I think the
results were the correct results mr.
seacord again I go back to this being
the bicentennial year of the
Constitution doesn't it not disturbed
you as an American setting aside your
own great confidence in yourself which
has been very clearly expressed to us
now you obviously have more confidence
than you have in the CIA in terms of you
said you cannot run their covert
operations better than they you have
more confidence in your legal judgment
than the a judgment of the Attorney
General whom you have roundly condemned
for making public the diversion of funds
you seem to have more confidence in
yourself than you do even the
president's own staff because you
drafted a speech to give to Colonel or
for the President of the United States
to read to explain this and you put
confidence in yourself in terms of
opening the new channel of
communications you think it is
appropriate for private American
citizens without any position of
authority in this country and not
accountable in any way to the Congress
of United States to be exercising the
making of foreign policy decisions of
this kind when funds generated from the
sale of American taxpayers property the
money generated from the sale of
American taxpayers property to the
Iranians now is it right for you as a
private individual to use American
taxpayers money to make these kinds of
decisions even when the National
Security Council albeit a shockingly low
level at the National Security Council
is telling you not to continue
I find it difficult to respond to that
string of assertion understand why you
find it difficult to respond because the
concern have you ever read the
Constitution the United States mr.
seacord
yes senator ball even of course I've
sworn to uphold it and I fought for it
quite a few times I understand you have
fought for it no one that takes anything
away from that but is it does it not
trouble you did you not wake up some
morning and think how did I as a private
individual start exercising all this
responsibility to make foreign policy
for the United States of America in lieu
of the Congress the Secretary of State
the President of the United States
members of the National Security Council
did that not did you not have even a
moment of humility about your judgment
and substituting yourself for the
constitutional process of this country
well I don't agree with what you're
saying about what I did I thought I was
doing the right things that time but I
can tell you I was troubled all along
the way trouble or trouble yes sir that
reassures me now you have a strategic
graph of what is going on in Central
America because you're making these
important decisions how often have you
been to Central America beg your pardon
sir how often have you physically been
to Central America as I think I
testified I never went to Central
America except for one brief trip in
April last year April of last year
and we're in Central America did you go
in April was El Salvador so he went to
El Salvador how long did you stay and
what day was that maple recall I don't
have that date but it's in April and it
was for less than one day less than one
day how long were you actually on the
ground or flying over El Salvador I
understand you you took a flight from
one airstrip to another and then you
came back to the original destination
and flew out is that correct yes sir so
how long did all of that tank again I'm
guessing but I would say six hours six
hours so you've been in Central America
for six hours mr. seacord is you a
private citizen of substituting your
judgement of the National Security
Council the Bureau of the Central and
Latin American affairs of the State
Department people that have studied this
for years
lived in the region but it did worry you
what you were doing that I was not
substituting my judgment for theirs I
was trying to run a very small operation
to do what I thought was an important
job now let me let me ask you about
profit motive you've said that in all of
this you had no profit motive and that
you renounced any profits that you might
make isn't it true though that in terms
of your conversation with our staff when
you were being questioned that you
commented that while you and mr. Hakim
did not expect to or at least you did
not expect to make or desire to make a
profit out of the current operation but
you felt that if you could open the door
to improve relationships between the
United States and Iran given the fact
that you had previously represented this
government in Iran when you were an
official of this government and you had
particularly dealt with the Shah and his
government in the arms field mr. Hakim
was involved in the armaments field
during that same period is it not true
that you told our staff during
questioning by them that you and mr.
Hakim had talked about the fact that
once the channels were opened he really
saw a great opportunity to make a good
deal of money in terms of of taking
advantage of that new openness between
her and the United States yes sir so
it's not really quite correct to say
that that evil thought of making a
little profit down the road didn't just
lurk somewhere in the back of your mind
through all this well I'm I'm like mr.
Liman I'm not a philanthropist either I
have my living I understood that all
along but I you just keep rejecting the
word profit like you think it's
something ugly you call it the
difference you call it the surplus you
call it the build-up of the capital
account of the enterprise you seem so
intent on saying to the American people
that you never
had any thought of profit as a
motivation in the short run or in the
long run for this project and that
really isn't at least in the long run
you had a little little hope in June I
didn't testify that I didn't hope to
make profit in the long run and I told
your staff that that's why you know it I
want to make that clear do you know mr.
Edwin P Wilson have you been acquainted
with mr. Edwin P Wilson
I knew him many years ago many years ago
how many years ago I think the last time
I saw him was in I can't recall 79 80 79
80 well that's not not too long ago in
the sweep of history the you've been
you've told us that you renounced your
profits because you wanted to come back
into government I gather what you're
really saying is that you wanted your
reputation kept intact you didn't want
anyone to raise any question that you'd
been self-interested you wanted to
protect your reputation so you would be
in a position to come back into
government that correct yes sir
well thinking about your reputation and
much has been said about that and many
of the your good good services to this
country been outlined by counsel
especially by a minority house counsel
talked about your years of duty in the
armed services the decorations you've
had didn't it concern you as a as a
person concerned about his reputation
that your association with mr. Edwin P
Wilson and let me just for the record
state I would ask you if this sounds
accurate to you that mr. Wilson in 1983
was convicted in Eastern District of
Virginia for conspiracy to illegally
export firearms mr. Wilson was convicted
in the Southern District of Texas in
1983 for conspiracy to export illegally
plastic explosives mr. Wilson was
convicted in 1983 in the Southern
District of New York for conspiracy to
murder federal witnesses
I don't see what the relevance of any of
this is I think we're getting we're
descending very quickly into character
it's a scintilla with chairman if you
will allow me to complete my question I
can very quickly draw this connection
now that's the record of mr. Wilson
during the course of the investigation
conducted by the FBI and others and to
mr. Wilson's conduct that led in part to
these convictions you were interviewed
as in the course of that investigation
were you not mr. seacord yes sir and is
it not true then in the course of that
investigation you indicated that you
knew mr. Wilson well enough that he
frequently gave you the use and I'm sure
as a pilot and enjoy flying the use of a
twin-engine aircraft for your personal
use for a short period of time yes for a
short period of time when he lets you
use it well I believe as a twin-engine
Seneca wasn't it a twin-engine beach
twin-engine beach that mr. Wilson kindly
provided for you what was your we're
doing the employ of United States
government at that time yes sir
what was your position at that time at
the time I was director of international
programs headquarters Air Force the
director of international program
international programs during all of
this period of time or what other what
other positions did you hold during that
turn in 1981 I would say from 1980 to 83
okay in 1981 I was appointed Deputy
Assistant Secretary of Defense for the
Middle East in 1981 and 81 and then what
then following that what was it that was
it and these in these positions did you
have and of course you had dealt when
you were in Iran what was your what was
your function there chief of the Air
Force section of the military advisory
group and in these various positions
that were you in a position to advise
various governments and to participate
in internal discussions of weapons
systems and weapons sales and purchases
yes sir did you not think that it would
be inadvisable for a man as concerned
about his reputation as u2 except for
mr. Wilson the note
arms-dealer the use of a private
airplane during this period of time in
which you were an official of the
government of the United States at the
time when that you're referring to I
thought that that he was an honorable
man I had no idea what he was involved
in and and mr. Boren I was investigated
as you also well know for what almost
three years and was and was cleared was
given a letter by Justice it was found
that you had not broken the law it was
not found that you had not conducted
your say it was not you were not get us
given a certification that to use have
the use of a plane of a person like mr.
Wilson was appropriate or a laudatory
behavior let's be sure about what the
record said at the but the Justice
Department doesn't issue those kinds of
statements no that don't but I think all
of us as public officials have a have a
responsibility of determining the
propriety of our conduct let me let me
go into some of the other people with
which you've been associated you said
yesterday that you you had nothing to do
with the Stanford Technology Corporation
in the California corporation and I
believe you said on Monday you said
quote you from the transcript which I
have no association and never did never
did have any association quote unquote
from the transcript now it's come out
even Henry's transferred Technology
Corporation of California I quote here
let me just go into this mr. seacord
yes that is confusing and often it is
reported in the press incorrectly mr.
Hakim has a company which he owns named
Stanford Technology Corporation of
California now a California corporation
he has had this name on several
different companies and there this is a
company with which I have had no
association never did never did have any
association now you indicated today in
your answers I was listening to you very
carefully you first said oh yes I was on
the board of that company for a little
bit back in 82 or 83
and then you were corrected that indeed
according to the minutes which mr. Lyman
went into that you became a board member
in 1983 now I think was 1984 senator
1980 I mean in 1985 I'm sorry 85 I
thought it was 80 and I thought it was
84 so you have been associated with it
I've never been to a single board
meeting I never had any dealings you're
unaware that mr. frank terpil was now a
fugitive from justice was the
distribution representative for that
particular company in Washington DC
completely unaware and I've never met
the man and never laid eyes on right
well you do know mr. Thomas Klein's
don't you yes sir
and as I recall on on Monday you talked
glowing terms about mr. Klein's you said
you had great confidence in mr. Klein
that's correct
one of the reasons you brought him on
board yes had confidence I think yes sir
I'm sure you know and I believe you've
indicated to our staff that you're aware
of the EA t SCO case the yes sir it's
gold it's go case you're well well aware
of that
of course what what what was involved in
mr. Klein's in that case but the bottom
line was that mr. Klein's
one of mr. clients companies was fined
by judge in 1980 1984 for for over
billing the US government so you knew
about that I found out about it is it
and wouldn't rabbis wouldn't surprise
you and let me just summarize this limo
before me and would not surprise you to
hear that On January 16th 1984 system
services International SSI pled guilty
in US District Court Eastern Division of
Virginia Richmond the one count criminal
information charging SSI was filing
false invoices with the DoD
ay-ay-ay relating to the cost of
shipping military goods to egypt from
the foreign military sales act the plea
of guilty was entered now let me change
the SSI stock next paragraph SSI was
fine the maximum penalty of $10,000
pursuant to a plea agreement between the
United States and SSI the agreement
further provided that Thomas Klein's on
behalf of SSI would pay the United
States one hundred thousand dollars
within 30 days in settlement of all
additional civil claims the plea of
guilty was entered by the president sole
stockholder of SSI Thomas G Klein's that
doesn't surprise you to learn that I
knew it at the time you know at the time
and yet this is the man with whom you
chose to form a business relationship to
have him come and be involved in the
operations that were ongoing yes senator
he's a friend of mine I testified to
that and you knew you knew also that he
had that he had access to this very
sensitive encrypting equipment that had
been provided to you by NSA and others
the no he did not you did not know that
mr. Klein's
had that equipment he did not have that
equipment he never communicated to you
on it no never
she knew you knew mr. Klein's having
pled guilty to submitting false invoices
now mr. client mr. Hakim
he's your principal partner in this
operation I guess you would say now he
was operating in Iran when you were
there representing US government that's
right now are you aware of the fact that
mr. Hakim has also had his legal
problems now when I first went into
partnership with him I was not aware but
I've subsequently become aware that he's
had some legal problems when did you
become aware Oh a year or so out into
our association didn't know that he was
involved in a case of
now 1983 involving a u.s. arms
manufacturer in which he was asked to
provide a deposition about payments to
the former employee of this company that
were unauthorized payments I had no idea
and I don't know that he did anything
wrong I still don't do you know that in
his deposition in that particular case
federal court in New Haven Connecticut
that mr. Hakim admitted that he had been
involved in the payment of bribes to
high Iranian government officials this
was during the period of the Shah to
induce them to purchase certain
equipment from this particular firm I've
never read into documents I've heard
some her seen some press reports so so
you were aware of these Press reports
that he had that he had been involved in
this yes but I don't know that he's done
anything wrong
he was an Iranian he admitted in a
deposition if he admitted you said
you've seen the press reports that when
he was an Iranian citizen that he was in
the business of expediting contracts by
preying paying bribes to companies I
don't know if I'm not wrong that's I'm
not arguing with you I'm just saying I
don't know what he did wrong he was an
Iranian citizen working according to
Iranian standards as far as we're aware
he had some legal problems yes indeed
sir all right ask you know when we when
they got in trouble in November of 1985
about this Israeli ship shipment of the
80 Hawks through Portugal and they asked
you to step in I believe that that there
was a conversation reflected in
documents
that we have had access to that
indicates that attempts were made once
you were called in your associates to
pay some compensation to people let's
put it this way make some payments to
people in Portugal to get these
shipments out of Portugal and that
trying to expedite the thing in that
manner is that true the first time I've
ever heard such a thing you've never
heard of any any conversation about that
at all no I'm not sure like see your
documents senator well I don't know
whether you're cleared to see that well
maybe maybe you don't understand them
too you know so you you you did you I
remind you you're under oath you had no
discussion and you know of no discussion
by your associates with anyone in
Portugal in November of 1985 in regard
to making payments to expedite the
movement of those particular pieces of
only to the extent that we promised the
Deaf X corporation that their costs and
their normal fee would be covered
because they were expected to handle the
transit meant well now you said that's
that's a qualifying statement of course
it is it's the truth let me go back to
my question and you then know to the
extent the deaf X was making payments of
this kind that there had been discussion
of making payments of this kind is that
correct I said that I promised def X
that would reimburse them for any costs
that they incurred of course they never
incurred any cost and that we would pay
whatever their normal fee is yeah let me
ask let me ask the question again I'll
try to restate it exactly as I did
before because I don't believe your
answer is response to you after I remind
you you are under oath
did you are did anyone associated with
you have any conversation or did you
hear any discussion or have you heard
then or since then any discussion of any
payments being made by anyone to people
in Portugal
for the purpose of getting those
shipments expedited I'm talking here
about people that are portuguese
officials either running airports or
customs or any kind of association
official association no I didn't hear
anything like you have not no let me
just ask general Secord it troubles me
because you're obviously our person that
is proud of your reputation why in the
world paraphrase an old saying with a
sterling fellow like you get caught
associating with people like mr. Wilson
like mr. Hakim and like mr. Kline's
what's a nice fellow like you doing in
an operation like that senator mr.
Wilson when I met him was an honorable
man I thought and he was a servant of
the government I had no idea what he was
going to get involved in later with
respect to the other two gentlemen
you've mentioned I consider them both to
be good friends good Americans
they worked hard did the best they could
under very difficult so good Americans
someone who has admitted to defrauding
the government gob States by filing
false and did admit that he pled guilty
to finally guilty to it a company pled
guilty yes the Charlie plays a big
difference because he wanted to get out
of that mess was going on and on it was
a settlement I would certainly think
that he was a settlement an agreement
like that he would an agreement center
well let me ask you were you were you
denied as security clearance to your
knowledge and October of 1983 I was not
aware of it till I read the the memo
they showed me this morning so you don't
dispute the fact that you were denied a
security clearance in October of 1983
well I wasn't aware of at the time but
you but you don't dispute that and why
was I denied a clearance because the
council see I said that the Justice
Department said my the investigation of
me was continuing and
in January or February and we have the
letter here we received a letter from
the Justice Department which closed the
case well let's go into events since
then as mentioned yesterday I believe by
the minority council about your service
on the special operations policy
advisory groups post so pag yes sir
and you were commended I believe by the
council for that he listed that among
your other contributions to the country
when did you leave so PAC when did you
when did you terminate as a member of so
PAC I can't give you a date I think it
was last summer something like that they
terminated my my membership determined
they terminated remember yes it was not
a voluntary leaving on your part no why
did they terminate your membership on
that well I think they had reasons I
think they had two reasons alright one
was concerned that there would be some
notoriety in the wind and because the
assistant secretary there knew exactly
was briefed on the operation it was
involved in with respect to Iran and
secondly because they sent me another
set of financial statement forms to fill
out
I had already filled out my financial
statement forms and didn't send them in
so they terminated me they didn't
contact me and call me they didn't say a
thank you wouldn't disagree with the
testimony that was given by Secretary of
Defense this matter to a congressional
committee I quote I quote Secretary of
Defense's testimony and then asked if
you have any disagreement with it major
general Secord served on the special
operations policy advisory group from
January 1984 to August 1986 he last
participated in November 1985 his
membership on so pag was terminated
effective the 4th of August 1986 based
upon his failure to provide the
Department of the financial information
as required
is there any disagreement with that no
all right let me ask you about your
security clearance we talked about the
earlier refusal to grant a clearance to
you in 1983 what about the current
status of your security clearance are
you the holder of a security clearance
at this time I don't believe I am
anymore
when was that terminated I can't I
couldn't give you a date senator I don't
know
well let me I don't have any need for a
security clearance I don't have one
well you certainly had a need for it
back during an earlier period of time
here because you were dealing with a
covert action which requires top secret
code word clearance which is above the
top secret clearance level
well I sorts the records and I can't
find you ever had the codeword clearance
required I've had it one for years you
had oh yes you had one for years yes SC
I well totally matter I did in the it's
a matter of rate of this but it's not
totally reflect well then you have you
certainly didn't have it to 1983 you
didn't have any clearance in August of
1983 when the when they government
declined to give you any yes I did I had
a defense for ongoing investigate Argan
log well but that was a CI clearance
you're talking about there I still had a
Defense Department clearance you do I
did you did yes
well according the information given to
me by the Department of Defense Office
of General Counsel your top secret
security clearance was withdrawn as a
result of your failure to comply with
the appropriate security forms necessary
and that also includes the filing of
financial information necessary for the
conduct of a periodic reinvestigation in
accordance with standard DoD policy this
matter was first raised in June of 1986
again in November of 1986 when the
department requested that you submit
nudee deform 49 February and March of
1987 you were they were again advised
it's not received and to initiate
appropriate action withdraw your
top-secret clearance which I've
indicated has been canceled now why you
so reluctant to so it so I had the
clearance that I said I had during the
timeframe we were discussed was that let
me go back you know here we have you on
so pag and you're removed for failure to
provide financial information and now we
have a security clearance in the
Department of Defense cancels your
security clearance for failure to
provide financial information the secret
why are you so reluctant to provide
financial information of this government
that you not only lecture so anxious to
serve why didn't you do it then I called
the official concerned when I received
those forms their laborious forms to
fill out I filled them out many many
times it's troublesome we in Congress
have to fill out financial disclosures
I'm aware of that troublesome they take
time and their bother well you don't
give me a chance to answer senator
please do I called the official who was
involved in this and said look I've
filled out these forms yet do I have to
fill them out every six months you know
that's the last I heard from them until
very recently I got a communication well
there I would and I was rather busy
during that period I wasn't thinking
about understand you've been awfully
busy and unable to provide a lot of
financial details you've been busy
I think I let me I think I've provided
an enormous amount of financial detail
well I guess we all have to draw our own
conclusions about no doubt let me um
well let me just say that when it comes
down to the record your own actions that
you have been terminated in terms of
your security clearance by the
Department of Defense and your
membership on policy advisory group both
terminations were for your failure to
submit updated financial information let
me go back to the question that you were
asked this morning about the ownership
that you have of all of these airplanes
air strips the whole airlift operation
as I understand that that was a
purchased with funds either contributed
to the Contras with general or which mr.
Claro paid into your accounts I believe
there was a total in addition of thirty
million dollars mentioned on Monday
there was a total of seventeen million
additional that went through the
accounts under the control of yourself
and mr. Hakim or into the system as we
might call it of the enterprise came
into the enterprise these other funds
being funds mr. Claro got from
contributions of other sources and and
so these were the funds that were used
to buy the aircraft and the airstrip
right the whole mechanism now since this
was money or money that you had donated
out of the arms fund sale to the Contras
since all this was money donated to the
Contras then how in the world can you
say that you have a right to give this
to anybody how can you say it's yours
how can you say belongs to the
enterprise doesn't this belong to the
Contras it was bought with money
contributed to the Contras the money
you're talking about it the assets
you're talking about where the the
property of one of the companies and as
I've tried to become the property of one
of the companies since it was all
purchased with wasn't it purchased for
the conference it was purchased to
support the Contras purchase to support
but yes with funds donated to help the
Contra that's correct and that's where
they went
that you had decided to sell you said
you wanted to donate it you told mr.
Casey does anyone else present when you
a told that mr. Casey have testified
that it was one-on-one I went on with
mr. Casey both times so yes and you said
you were gonna give that away mm-hmm
tragically of course mr. Casey he's not
here to tell us what was said in those
conversations but both conversations
were one-on-one with mr. Casey only now
if you decided you said you decided that
you wanted to give it away even though
over several months you testified this
morning you were aware of and you
checked in with mr. Dutton about his
pulling together these figures right now
but let's suppose you decided to sell it
to the CIA say you wanted to sell could
you have would have been legal I assume
it would be yes how would it have been
legal but after all all the funds to
purchase all these things they were
really in kind contributions to the
Contras we're gained from donations from
people it didn't say we're giving this
money to benefit lake resources or
southern air somebody else he said we're
giving this money to benefit cumference
if it were done the funds would have
gone back into the the accounts of which
we loosely referred to as lake resources
now tell me again why you wanted mr.
Dutton to do all this work preparing all
these cost figures and estimates on this
memorandum that you said you checked in
with him several times over quite a few
months as he was getting this
information together why did you haven't
go to all that trouble if you had
already decided and you'd already
privately and secretly one-on-one told
mr. Casey you're gonna give it all away
unless of your miss memorandum served a
lot of purposes it had pulled together
the reorganization that was underway
there had to be a reorganization because
the system was broken and it wasn't
working and that was the principal
function of mr. Dutton during this time
payment
time frame
so you wanted to pull together to show
the value and we did pull it together
and the purpose was gonna show to see
how valuable we pulled the operation
together senator and started making it
successful for the first time in about
that time for our Wow all right now you
pulled all this information together
there were these various that why were
all these options laid out if you'd
already decided to give it away because
the CIA I was being told by Colonel
north I didn't talk to the CIA never
about this except to in general terms to
the director as I've testified to
but Colonel north was telling me that
the CIA didn't want to touch these
assets because they were tainted I ran
through that in my testimony I couldn't
see how they could retain it I thought
it was a very valuable asset I thought
it was something that was needed it was
in place it was finally functioning
that's something that we needed to
support the contours and it was in that
vein that we pulled this information
together to show how valuable it was as
an asset because we're gonna give it to
that's what I told you're planning to
give it to them now it's interesting to
me on the land on the airport and you
show the airport is a million dollar
asset that correct it was actually we're
on the hook for five million dollars for
a but you didn't show that mr. Dutton's
memo doesn't show said you're on the
hook it was to have a balloon payment
the next year or five million dollars
was enough no several years later that
payment was gone out of the future so if
you'd given it to the CIA if you'd
showed them this memo you put together
showing years a million dollar ass that
we're giving you
you're really giving him a five million
dollar liability weren't you no we had
made some payments and we had some more
payments to make on that governor giving
it to him right at the moment as of the
time of that memo was put together you
were giving them a potential liability
of five million dollars down the road
where you know possibly there was
tremendous little piece of land wasn't
that put in the report so the CIA would
be aware I don't know the rosti of the
gift I don't know
the CIA was completely aware of the
terms they were completely aware yes
they were now let's go back to this
control of the accounts that we've gone
into you stated on Monday that you had
oral control mr. Hakim he operated these
financial accounts but that you had oral
control of these accounts is that
correct
yes sir you could direct the control of
these various accounts of the enterprise
yes sir orally now under the definition
of our tax laws if you control funds if
their funds under your control arguably
their your your funds did you um so if
you have six million dollars like we
said there's six and a half million
still in the fiduciary account various
accounts a bunch of names and mr.
Hakeem's Correll and hard for me to keep
up with all these names of all these
shall accounts sitting over there
million and a half still directly in the
enterprise counts two million somewhere
it was unaccounted for out of the 30
another two million out of the 17
million that appears to be in mr.
Hakeem's mr. Hakeem's accounts I count
up 12 million if you take the full 47
million you know you took 30 million and
you said there was one and a half and
the enterprise still there was six seven
years yes there's a question I I am and
Tim to ask a question right that I hope
that the witness will answer would like
to hear it I'm summarizing his his
statement to me and I want to ask him he
had oral control over this money there
were six and a half plus one and a half
stone the enterprise plus to me and
unaccounted for according to your
statements on Monday and then out of the
second 17 million so that's ten million
out of the second seven out of the 17
million but also flowed through the toy
out of the table 47 there's another two
million that apparently went into either
to mr. Hakim or into a CD additional CD
so 12 million altogether is that
basically correct I could I couldn't
follow the latter part of it I followed
you the first part you you remember the
30-man you said it where it is true that
eight million either and mr. Hakim
fiduciary and and the one 1/2 million
stone the enterprise so total of eight
six and a half one and a half right and
there was two million for which you
could not account so we're not quite
sure where that went you said that was
not a candidate you didn't know might be
overhead be accounting hasn't been done
yet county's not done so we don't know
where that to meeting is now there was
seventeen million more that came in to
the enterprise
this was the money that Calero put in
and so on and out of that seventeen
million as I've gone through the
accounting that we have available for
mr. Hakim it appears there's another two
million out of that that either is in a
CD or it's in it's been distributed to
mr. Hakim because there's another two
men unaccounted for and I'm unaware you
don't know whether it's ten million or
12 million that we're dealing with ten
million from your earlier testimony on
Monday see they're ten or twelve million
either way given them the kind of
ballpark figures that have been given
here in terms of a couple million of
overhead not accounted for the let me
just ask didn't you have you did have a
little control over those funds did you
report him for tax purposes no sir why
didn't I didn't think was required
anything is required he know you had
oral control did you file a tax return
for the year 1985 it's not yet filed
under ATO 485 484 I've turned over my
Ritu by 85 we haven't had the pilot I've
returned him over to you we've gone
through it I won't take any more one one
last bit here just to clarify one last
point yes sir before I quit
we had distributions mentioned this
morning into these various accounts for
example according to mr. Hakeem's
records we had a distribution out of the
central account to corral for $26,000 to
Hakim for 26,000 to SciTech great
thousand sixty one thousand distributed
out on
what looks like a three-way split five
2086 on six to 86 we had 263,000
distributed out according to Mister
Hakeem's records to SciTech Corral
Hakeem and CT that looks like a 30 30 30
10 split June 19th the 1986 you had
$26,000 of distributed out again the
same company same kind of split
percentage-wise 828 86 860 1000 was
distributed out SciTech or lct and
Hakeem again the same kind of same kind
of splits would it surprise you that mr.
Hakim ledgers there are also references
to disbursements to you one hundred one
thousand one hundred eighteen thousand
gives account numbers this is in a
period from 84 to 86 April 86 there's
another one of over a hundred thousand
one hundred eighteen thousand another
hundred one thousand and that these
account numbers at least according to
mr. Hawkins ledger sheets also match up
not only they say they say Richard
Secord or rvs and they also match up
with the the Corl account would that
surprise you I haven't I haven't seen
the records you've got there senator I
have not seen you haven't had any access
to look at mr. Hawkins Ledger's no would
it surprise you that some of these
account numbers for Corral or you have
obviously a distribution of a split of
money of proceeds of some kind on a
thirty thirty thirty ten basis appear to
match up the same account numbers with
your name without surprise you if that
were true I don't know about the
allocations I'd like to look at the
records we tried to do some of that map
the other day and we weren't able to
come up with that need a picture so you
simply don't know no now let me let me
get down at the bottom line mr. C Gordon
Oh complete my colleagues are being very
patient with me we have records from mr.
Hakim
some records from mr. Hakim that
indicated where the first money came
into the enterprise a partial readout on
Lake resources accounts and so on as
I've indicated there somewhere and we
can argue about the figure where there's
8 million 10 million or 12 million but
there's a substantial amount of money
here you said six and a half million is
in these various accounts that you call
fiduciary accounts of mr. Hakim several
million dollars in these accounts you do
understand don't you that this committee
has not been provided with records that
trace where the money went after it went
in to these camps in other words money
is shown going out to corral I just
showed you 800 some thousand dollars now
once it gets into corral we don't have
any other records that indicates if it's
still there
if it's gone out someplace else because
we do not have the bank records for
corral do you understand that I did not
know it but I thought you had two bank
records we do not have the bank records
that go into where the money finally was
dispersed we have the first payments out
to the first shell corporations the
first the first level of where the money
went we do not have records as to where
the money went
we know it's paid out to various people
to CT whatever that means to corral
whatever that means to all these other
various accounts of various names we
know money was paid out disbursed and
according to your own math you told us
on Monday six and a half million dollars
in these various accounts or six and a
half million went to these various
accounts now we don't have bank records
that tell us if that money is still in
those accounts or if it's been
distributed out to any more questions
you understand that I understand what
you're saying I think you're gonna have
to pose that question to mr. huckey are
you aware of the fact that we do not
have that information I was not aware
that you didn't have the bank record mr.
Kord I thought you had the bank rest
stored we've discussed this you come
here and you've said to us you're very
very can this committee appreciates the
fact that you did not ask for immunity
to testify you came in and you've been
testifying here for three long days I'm
sure they've been very long days for you
we appreciate the fact that you've done
that you presented to yourself to the
American people by saying you've come
here to tell everything you have no
reservations you're laying it all out
for us and that you didn't get a penny
but you had no profit motive that all
this money was paid out into these
accounts and we know where the money
first went you know the accounts that
was first paid into but we don't know
where it's gone from there and we don't
know who ended up with it and in all
honesty we don't know if they're any
Richard V Secord accounts and any Swiss
bank doing just that you've heard from
me all we know is we have your word to
tell us that you don't have any account
let me ask you do you have any accounts
could you list for the committee that
accounts on which you are the signatory
there in this country or any other
country in the world including
Switzerland the Cayman Islands or
anywhere else any country could you list
for the committee the names of the
accounts that you have on which you have
drawing rights or signator rights or you
have any beneficial interest in now or
in the future would you name for the
committee right now those accounts on
which you are signature drawing rights
or have any beneficial interest in our
in the future this country or any other
country I'll be happy to submit a letter
to you and you will name them all yes
sir all right now we have we would have
your word for it you have my word we
would have your word for the fact that
that would be a full and complete list
of any account on which you have I'll
give you an affidavit well I I think
it's time for you to take the next step
so we don't have to just take your word
for it even your word for it under oath
and I say that with all respect I'd ask
remember the staff come forward we first
wrote in February and I have a letter
for mr. Lyman to you in February asking
for this waiver of authority so that we
can look at your bank records so that we
can determine it Switzerland for
ourselves objectively is there any
account of Richard BC Court exactly in
the form that your counsel knows about
our counsel
parrot it we have a notary here mr.
seacord and if you're telling the truth
to the American people and if you're
being totally candid and you want the
American people to know for sure that
you have not made a profit I would urge
you if you love this country and are
interested in full disclosure to sign
that waiver for us that we've been
negotiating with you with you since
February that we discussed with you
again on Monday you said you'd consider
it I seem you've had adequate time to
fully look into this matter I would urge
you to sign it right now to present it
to us he's gonna stand by his answer
before he's inclined to sign it he
probably will sign it and he'll rely on
the advice of counsel and will consider
and that's going to be a decision to
take no sir but I will give you a
decision just just as quickly as we can
focus on it I'm talking about days not
weeks so I will look forward to your
decision and I appreciate your patience
in answering my questions Thank You
senator I'm pleased now to recognize the
gentleman from Ohio congressman DeWine
thank you very much mr. chairman good
afternoon general
good afternoon sir general I'm going to
try to be try to be brief I just got a
few questions for you general wouldn't
you agree that ollie north was and is
let me see how I'm gonna say this sort
of given to the dramatic yes always a
very always a very enthusiastic marine
officer and his has certainly got a
certain mental dramatic flair sort of
flair for the flamboyant he's been
characterized that way a lot in the
press I don't I think its overstated but
it's there he could tell a pretty good
story could he not sure you know you
told us yesterday that Oliver North told
you that he had told the President of
the United States about this so-called
diversion
of the funds and in fact he had told the
president sort of laughed a little bit
about the fact that pilot Ola was in
fact supplying some funds that were
ultimately being used of the Contras yes
sir
you know you were skeptical of that
story were you not yes it doesn't sound
like the kind of story that one would
hear in the office of the
commander-in-chief in fact general when
you and I mr. green
Sunday night after a long day that we
had spent with counsel with mr. Stokes
with staff members walked out a capital
and walked towards our car my car was in
the parking lot yours was right fairly
close I asked you did I not said general
do you believe that story you recall
that yes sir and you told me at that
time did you not that you were skeptical
yes sir
to recall that you told me something
else as well that you told me at that
time that you were skeptical and you you
didn't know you weren't there but that
if you had to bet your last dollar on it
you wouldn't do it that's correct that
correct that is correct congressman your
opinion the same today has not changed
you know let me move if I could to the
deposition that you're questioned about
this morning this was a deposition and I
assume you have not seen the deposition
of Robert C Dutton yes sir I have not
seen it you had not seen that before
today
no I still have not seen it Friday
February 4th 1987 is the date on it over
the lunch hour I pulled that out in read
through it and I noticed this morning
general that you had a little difference
of opinion with what was read to you
from that transcript is that would that
be a fair statement yes sir like to read
to you another section of that
transcript that was not read to you this
morning I'm going to read it to you I
know you don't have it in front of you
and I would like to ask you whether or
not this is accurate or if you could
just comment on counsels benefit this is
on page 55 questioning by mr. buck
question you mentioned that this
document was to be presented to the CIA
to help them decide how to take over the
operation or whether to take over the
operation is that right answer it was
given to Colonel North to use however he
saw fit but question okay answer if you
wanted to use it as a talking paper want
to use it as a document to leave with
the CIA so they can know what was there
I don't know exactly how a handler but
that is what it was prepared for the
question I'm trying to determine whether
it was the intention of your company to
sell these assets to the CIA or not
answer if the CIA wanted to purchase
them then the idea was to sell them it
was also discussed that it could be
given to the
CIA question so you so you are unclear
about that answer that is correct that
was general C Court's decision on page
56 the next page this exchange takes
place question did he ever talk about a
profit that he would make from the CIA
answer no question you said that was
general C court's decision did he ever
communicate any feedback from the
discussions with the CIA whether this
would be a sale a gift reimbursement
answer no all he told me CIA decided
they would use our organization as the
core of their effort when they took over
the resupply operation could you have a
comment about that that was a portion of
the testimony from deposition taken made
4th 1987 Robert C Dutton that sounds
more like an accurate history
edye looked at it over the lunch hour
and had a very small portion of it
transcribed
I'd like to read it as a preface to my
question if I could this is bud
McFarlane I think barber than any in a
year's time a curious and haunting
factor that will come out in this
episode is the Vietnam War and I think
it should but is a factor in shaping
crit on Norris actions Barbara Walters
what do you mean buddy McFarland well
for people who went through that and
Colonel North surely did you come away
with the profound sense of very
intolerable failure that is that a
government must never give its word to
people who may stand to lose their lives
and then break faith and I think that
it's possible that in the last year
we've seen a commitment made to human
beings in Nicaragua that is being broken
question Barbara Walters and he was
trying to make up for it do you think
but McFarland I think that is very
likely general I note I noticed over the
weekend this council went through and we
went through the discussion with you
that a number of the people who were
involved in this operation were Vietnam
War veterans most uncommon veterans in
fact but McFarland yourself certainly
curled North several others do you think
that experience affected you and
affected the other people who were
involved in this in the way that bud
McFarlane is talking about here I did
not see the program but I'm a complete
accord with the cinema see you've just
read it and of course what respect why I
share with him the notion that we can't
keep breaking faith with people around
the world we've done it too many times I
could tick off a number of occasions
which have been very bad in Contra
situation is similar
did that in any way affect your attitude
towards what was going on in
specifically in regard to the resupply
yes sir I mean I undertook the resupply
operation against the advice of several
of my colleagues knowing that it was a
dangerous undertaking knowing that it
was vital however to the sustaining of
those troops in the field I was afraid I
had been told by people were supposed to
know that once they retired from the
field that would be very difficult to
ever get them back in there was a my
notion that this bridging action was
absolutely vital and of course I was
conditioned by my previous experiences
none of us who participated in that
conflict in Southeast Asia felt very
good about the ending so that's a
rambling answer to your question but but
the breaking faith aspect I have been
personally involved in programs
personally indirectly involved in
programs where we were supporting a
number of irregular groups specifically
the may or the Hmong in Laos the Kurdish
tribesmen along their iran-iraq border
to name two well-known examples and now
the Contras and which we have just
pulled out and left those people to die
and died they did you know yesterday
maybe even the day before we seems like
we've been here a long time you told us
that when this variant